leading recall candidate larry elder was
attacked by white liberals a woman
wearing a gorilla mask and they were
throwing eggs at him and i believe
someone with larry actually got punched
in the face because these people are
completely out of their minds
as you know there is a recall looming
the election is on the 14th i believe
it's september 14th and this could mean
that larry elder becomes governor now
the polls have started swinging in favor
of gavin newsom the democrat and there's
been a big push from democrats to quote
unquote stop the republican recall but
we'll see it's yet to be seen i think
the data is actually still favorable for
those who oppose newsome
again yet to be seen regardless i'm not
surprised this this kind of attack it's
it's absolutely disgusting so we'll get
into stories like that we also got joe
rogan
questioning whether he should sue cnn
because cnn's aaron burnett said that
joe rogan ingested livestock medicine
we got a lot to break down joe biden
apparently defying his handlers by
saying i'm supposed to leave and then
not leaving this is gonna be real
interesting and now he's trying to
dismantle this non-partisan military
panel so it should get pretty
interesting we got a couple of great
guests we are being joined by
pennsylvania senate candidate sean
parnell you want to just give a brief
introduction
hey i'm sean uh i'm running for senate
in in pennsylvania um endorsed by trump
uh just recently endorsed by trump uh
i'm an afghanistan combat veteran uh and
now i write books for a living and come
on your podcast a lot right now i love
it and we also got libertarian podcast
host peter quinones do you want to
introduce yourself i pronounce that
right right yeah man pretty good uh host
of the free man be on the wall podcast
and executive producer of the monopoly
the monopoly on violence which is a
documentary about the state
and
anarcho-capitalism
and libertarianism in general and that
is on amazon prime and yeah thanks for
having me and i feel like we just we
need to have a socialist in the room to
balance things out oh i could do that
i'll do that for you
what's up everybody i mean crossland i'm
a socialist
i like social programs actually i find
myself on the libertarian right these
days go game stunks we're just talking
about like the popular tim you were
saying there's six different political
factions at this point new york times
wrote an article where they're like here
are the six political factions within
the parties right now and it i think it
makes a lot of sense they say like the
growth and opportunity party are like
the trump supporters right-wing
populists american populists and they're
not christian conservatives because the
christian conservative is a separate
party and i think that makes sense so to
find myself as a populist uh
conservative populist just blows my mind
i mean i'm as a liberal you're not
concerned
not really no but i identify with that
movement right now isn't that the
weirdest thing though that like ian can
sit here and say a bunch of things that
people in the chat are like ian is
clearly a leftist but they will call him
right wing
by simply hanging out having these
conversations saying saying the
democrats are bad or whatever it's all
it takes
but all right we'll get some of that
balance it's not real hard man
when you have the left dominating
everything it's real easy to react and
go right
yep yep especially if you're
a logical thinker that's true and you're
seeing the size and scope of the federal
government grown
grow in ways that we have never seen
before in this country and not just not
just bureaucracy but the way that they
track people uh people's movements
social media all that stuff just
creates a sense of i think fear among
people who are afraid of losing losing
their their freedom
but i think you know you can look at
australia and you can see the quarantine
camps and all the insanity they're doing
with tracker apps and all that craziness
i think the u.s would shatter until a
million pieces before that would happen
here because you west virginia is not
going to be like on board with that
these these these mountain folk are
going to be like come and take it you
know what i mean but we'll get in all
this stuff we also got lydia she's
pressing all the buttons i am the
coroner today i was reading that
australia is confiscating alcohol from
australians whom they've put into
lockdown so i'm really curious if that
is what lights this on fire so i guess
we'll find out you can take a lot of
things away from people man but you take
their booze yeah that's not good all
right well before we get to the store
about larry elder make sure you go to
timcast.com become a member there will
be a members only podcast coming up we
usually publish around 11 or so pm that
is for members only but you will also
get access to all of our amazing
journalism without advertisements on it
and as a member you're helping support
us in our efforts to hire more people do
more shows we have a bunch of stuff in
the works i know that you know i've been
saying that for a long time because we
have this mystery show we're doing but
higher first you got to vet people first
you got to find somebody they got to vet
them then you got to you know interview
them then you've got to move them
halfway across the country then you've
got to pre so it takes a long time but
we've done live reads on the new shows
and it's going to be uh it's going to be
amazing so be a member but like this
video subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends sharing is
caring it's the most powerful thing you
can do if every single person who is
watching this show right now shared it
on social media we'd be bigger than cnn
in two seconds but if everybody did so
do your part and smash the like button
for ian a sad ian thank you it's your
like
true not so sad anymore i can feel it i
can feel the lights being tapped
well let's let's start off with this uh
this larry elder thing i got to be
honest you know i think there's so many
extremely important stories right now
we've got obviously the afghanistan
stuff which has been going on for a long
time especially with your your expertise
sean we could we could talk about this
but then as we're coming in and sitting
down i just i saw this story and for one
i'm like this one makes me really really
mad for a few reasons from timcast.com
breaking larry elder attacked by white
liberal in gorilla mask throwing eggs
now personally i don't know if liberal
is the right word to use
it is kind of kind of like the
colloquial word used for like the
opponents but this person's a nut
you know what i mean like i'm not gonna
i guess until the the mainstream
liberals come out and condemn this
actively i don't know what else to say
other than they're in the same under the
same umbrella but the story is
california gubernatorial candidate larry
elder was attacked by a white liberal in
a black and pink gorilla mask in venice
on wednesday the mask wearing leftist
was throwing eggs and shouting as elder
walked by the belligerent attacker also
punched a member of elders entourage who
was attempting to get them to calm down
and step away one of her friends also
punched him in the back of his head as
someone else threw an egg quote put your
hands on me again and i'll f you up the
ape masked attacker was heard shouting
another protester ranted to the media
present media present that elder who is
black doesn't even like his own people
quote a flying egg narrowly missed the
back of recall candidate larry elder's
head after was thrown by an activist
wearing a gorilla mask in venice a
scuffle broke out and the candidate was
escorted into an suv kate cagle the
journalist who filmed the incident wrote
in a tweet and i'll tell you what really
bothers me about this aside from the
fact that people are lunatics
is that
if this was someone on the right wearing
a gorilla mask and going up to a black
democrat it would have been it would be
the front page number one above the fold
new york times white supremacy that's
exactly where i was going to
thinking this the entire time as you as
you were speaking that yeah if this were
you know a someone on the right it would
be national news you'd have the today
show out there interviewing interviewing
people oh he was wearing a red hat you
know i mean you know that that would be
the dominant headline oh but i mean i
mean no but this is a gorilla and you
approached this
really really fair right like well this
guy is he's defined as as a liberal but
he's probably just somebody that's
struggling or oh i i didn't see the news
but right yeah but um
but yeah it's just someone that's a
little crazy you know that not really a
liberal but but if it were a
conservative you would get no such grace
this is this is from anybody this is
what they're saying right so the l.a
times called larry elder the black face
of white supremacy yeah it's insane
which is insane and then a leftist
wearing a gorilla mask throws eggs and
punches someone in his group
where's all of the headlines where's don
lemon saying ladies and gentlemen white
supremacy is alive in this country are
you a white man a white woman in a
gorilla mask attacking a black you don't
see it because it's not about race not
about racism all this critical theory
stuff is just we want power
and the double standards fairly obvious
isn't it well
isn't this the
you just look at this and you're like we
need to break up
we need to break up just go
think about what did you just say you
just said that
the press
controls the narrative
until the right gets a way to control
the narrative
they're always going to be in charge i
mean they've spent the last century
taking over academia and the press
i mean well of course you're you're so
you're so right and i think for years
what the dynamic was at least for the
last 15 or 20 years
the left would set their talking points
and what's interesting about the modern
day left or the the new democrat party
is their talking points are set by three
or four people at the top of their party
and they trickle down to the rest of the
party which is why a congressman in in
western pennsylvania espouses the same
views as a congresswoman in southern
california as in southern florida
they're all the same um so they they set
these talking points and then they'd in
the past they'd use the media to amplify
these talking points but over time as as
the market changed and stuff you had fox
news created and talk radio and
conservatives had their alternative
media but what what i think is so
dangerous today
is so you've the same dynamic between
democrats setting their talking points
and the media helping to elevate them
but now you have big tech
who is censoring any conservative
counterpoint and i think one of the
greatest
threats that we face as a country today
is the collusion between
uh the the modern day democrat party big
tech big business and and big media and
to to sort of take people's freedom away
from them and so you were talking about
like
some sort of alternative alternative
media hopefully over time we'll get
there but
as long as big tech can shut your
showdown i mean look look at this stuff
they could shut your showdown tonight if
they wanted to well i will say a lot of
people
have taken for granted the what the
internet has given them or i shouldn't
say it that way that's the wrong way to
put it you can't go on tucker carlson's
show and say
a lot you can't there's a lot of stuff
you can't say on fox news that's true
we're actually we actually have way more
leeway here on youtube but there's also
things that they can say that we can't
because youtube has editorial guidelines
which are not about community standards
so that is a very serious problem but
i'll tell you you know one of the
biggest problems is
and you can see how the left reacted to
this especially in how they threw eggs
at larry elder
the right never fought back the the the
american right seemed to think that
appointing judges solved the problem and
it didn't the cultural institutions are
where everything comes from and flows
from and big tech is involved in that
and i think a really good example of the
problem
the new york times
can just take any story
say it and every conservative
immediately pivots to address whatever
the new york times told them to talk
about
so there can be some big news like right
now larry elder gets attacked this white
liberal she's a racist white supremacist
i'll say
absolutely how dare she do that and
you're not going to see it in the media
joe rogan right we'll get to this in a
minute in greater detail but joe rogan
talks on his instagram channel about
what his doctors prescribe him and cnn
says he's taking livestock medicine
even though people don't trust the media
independent
i mean the media has very little trust
across the board
even with that still they set the
conversation and something i'll tell you
what's interesting the ukraine gate
stuff with joe biden
when that stuff was going down and i was
researching what was going on with
barisma the corruption of the biden
family i found a lot of uh damning
information but i had to go to eastern
european sources and vet them and it was
very difficult because i'm like i don't
know what these people are right i don't
know if these are credible sources i
don't know why i should trust cnn for
that instance in that in that
circumstance but the interesting thing
was this is considered fringe because
cnn didn't mention it if cnn doesn't
talk about it and you do it's irrelevant
fringe conspiracy crackpot nonsense
regardless of whether or not cnn or the
new york times or any of these outlets
is talking about something true or false
if you talk about anything off the path
of their controlled narrative and
opposition or or support then you're in
fringe territory that's something that
needs to change the right need to figure
out how to actually set the tone and set
the conversation well you have to also
ask
is the press doing
politicians bidding or are politicians
doing the press's bidding i've i have a
friend who was a reporter and he said he
stood he was in rooms where he watched
reporters bully politicians into
positions oh yeah so look at fouchy and
the mask thing look at the last four
look at the last five years i mean from
two from 2016 to 2018 the republicans
had
the executive the judiciary and and the
legislative they couldn't get anything
done and then right-wingers were like oh
well that's because the left i'm like
yeah that's because you guys had
you guys thought you had power but the
left was still in power yep and until
people start realizing that and start
looking for alternatives
look at look at this look at russia
the the the mainstream media comes out
and says oh russia russia russia because
hillary clinton said so said so and the
republicans in 2016 and 2018 were like
well you know we should reasonably look
at this and then ukraine gate happens
and it's nothing
this is the problem the republicans you
know what i think it was i think that we
had a uniparty for a long time
republicans and democrats basically the
same thing so the republicans were like
rolling their eyes we don't care about
trump we don't want any of this
but the populist right gaining more and
more power
and they're forced to reckon with it so
i think uh next year 2022 we might see
something really really fascinating that
that being said we might see something
crazy if larry elder becomes governor of
california
yes and by the way there are so many
angles to talk about this uh this very
problem from but what you were talking
about about joe biden and and verism in
ukraine and the whole like you know i
said you know fire the prosecutor who is
investigating
my son or my family for corruption or
you don't get the billion dollars right
that is a clear-cut
quid pro quo we'll have to break that
one down though
sure but i'm just saying from 30 000
feet right
you've got joe biden having a
conversation with the president of
afghanistan six weeks before the the
withdrawal four weeks before
the the the collapse of kabul the
conversation went hey you know uh
talking to the president of afghanistan
paint an overly rosy picture of what's
happening on the battlefield essentially
lie to the world to make it seem like
the taliban is isn't as strong as they
are or you don't get the military
assistance it's essentially the same
thing except for
the media just flies cover for him
i can make it very very simple
i love asking this question and uh i'm
gonna ask it now of all of you
do you think that if uh dave rubin after
he got suspended on twitter that twitter
was scared he would show up to twitter
hq with a mob of classical liberals with
pitchforks and torches and bricks start
violently attacking people do you think
jack dorsey was like guys we suspended
dave rubin it's gonna get violent here
we have to we have to unban him you
shouldn't have done this
no absolutely not do you think jack
dorsey had that conversation when they
talked about banning antifa
yes
when they say okay we've got these
people advocating for violence on our
platform what do we do if we start
banning them they're going to come after
us they're going to show up at the
headquarters they're going to smash
things the cops will be powerless
so here's what happens
when when when you you have these people
showing up throwing eggs at larry elder
you have uh
these politicians getting attacked when
when the right holds a rally in in the
pacific northwest antifa shows up and
starts attacking people and shooting at
them and now i'll tell you this it's
definitely escalated the point where i
would consider a lot of it to be mutual
combat in the pacific northwest but if
people say i'm gonna have a free speech
rally it's permanent leave us alone and
you show up you started the fight
the right doesn't have any kind of
threat factor they shouldn't the left
shouldn't either but so long as cops are
unwilling to do anything about it
people are going to continually fear
what the left does we were talking about
this the other day
that you know why is it these
institutions like the new york times or
whatever ultimately become woke well
it's because the regular people there
are too scared to say anything because
the the leftists are just terrifying and
fringe lunatics and there's very few of
them but everyone's scared of them and
that's it so long as people are scared
and unwilling so so my respect to larry
elder calmly walking and saying and
ignoring them can i posit a theory on
that sure
i think the left likes chaos and the
right even if they can't
even if they don't know how to say it
they like order i mean look at right
wing cities
small towns they're
you're not having an antifa problem look
where the left
governs it's a mess
it's always a mess and
why does the left like disorder like
that because the more disorder there is
the more power that they can take to
themselves and say hey we're doing this
even if they're not doing that and they
may even
want
that disorder maybe that's what happened
last year they knew that they could grow
their power if they let all of this
insanity run through look i want to i'll
i'll say this i'll say this about about
what you were saying
it's
it's not like this is some crazy theory
right like the left has if you would
have told me that the modern-day
democrat party
uh four years ago would be advocating
for a position of defunding the police
wholesale right and
and just just anti-police rhetoric right
they walked that one back quick
they did but it has consequences and
you're seeing as you as you mentioned
like crime in almost every major
american city philadelphia in my case in
pennsylvania they also told the police
to stand down so they could have never
chaos i i i agree with you i agree with
you i'm just saying that they're
anti-cop rhetoric coupled with defund
the police coupled with mixed signals
from leadership creates chaos in in
their cities right primarily democrat
power centers and you see that and you
see that empirically as well with rise
and murder rising crimes things like
that we got to go back to what you were
saying about barisma though because i
want to do uh um i want to uh
elaborate
and correct a little bit so uh you had
you had mentioned that you know joe
biden you know he goes to the prosecutor
and says shut down the investigation
into the corruption of my son otherwise
you're not getting the billion dollars
more specifically it was that
joe biden's son
for some reason was appointed to a board
member of a ukrainian energy company and
a lot of people wonder why that was the
case joe by a hunter biden's like look i
was an executive and i have experience
and i'm a lawyer and it's like sure okay
fine say whatever you want but the media
started saying there was no corruption
investigation into barisma it wasn't
into hunter biden it was into the
company and and uh micholis zlachevsky
the guy who founded the company
that was a lie matt tybee did excellent
reporting on this breaking down how
there was at least a dozen
investigations and i'll tell you the the
kicker it's been a while since i covered
all this stuff because i was talking
about how i had to go to foreign media
to find the stuff out the media control
of the narrative is so pronounced that
they wouldn't actually do the basic
investigation into what joe biden did
and what joe biden did was criminal and
corrupt
based on what i've researched to put it
simply
joe biden comes in
goes to the to the to the head of you
know the president of ukraine and says
either you fire the prosecutor or you're
not getting the billion dollar loan he
brags about it on video
so they do
now the prosecutor uh victor shoken says
he was investigating corruption matt
tybee confirms there was investigation
but tell you this the funny thing is
after they get rid of the prosecutor
who's a so biden says we we uh got rid
of the prosecutor because he wasn't
doing the investigation
funny story after the prosecutor got
ousted zlatski returned to ukraine from
exile got his money unfrozen when donald
trump comes in starts poking around dude
flees to monaco
tell me who is actually investigating
corruption
so i'll tell you this based on and it's
an older story but this is what the
media does
we see it over and over again with how
they frame things hunter biden's story
when that came out the laptop and the
leaked details and we knew like okay
this this is legit it's confirmed what
happened big tech came in and shut the
whole thing back absolutely absolutely
then that's my whole point so
you know leading people ask about the
the 2020 election and was it fair and
all this other stuff and i think there
are a lot of different layers to that
but
one of the reasons why
joe biden
uh is where he is today is because of
what you just said with regards to
censoring stories that were negative
about him and so we're seeing today you
know his poll numbers are falling for i
think a litany of reasons but you know
things are getting to a point whether
it's you know uh lackluster job growth i
mean the the the miss this last month
like i think what 725 000 jobs expected
225 000 added and then inflation which
is obviously we talked about this in the
last brutal and it primarily affects the
middle class and seniors on fixed
incomes be you know uh but also you're
looking at a wholesale collapse of
american foreign policy doctrine right
now you're seeing that most notably in
afghanistan
but the things that are happening now
are almost impossible to censor and they
don't really fit into the media
narrative and that the way that you know
that the situation in afghanistan was as
bad as it was is because msnbc and cnn
were actually reporting on it so you
know if they're reporting on it was ten
times worse than what it actually we're
seeing it here well come on
let's face it msnbc and the left media
loves war when was when was the first
time they praised trump when he dropped
bombs on syria
that's when he became presidential
we talked about this before the new york
times and msnbc helped lie us into the
war in iraq in in 2002 2003
they have
on meet the press there's
commercials for boeing
is the average meet the press person
watching meet the press in the market
for a 737
or is it a payoff of some sort
let's look i want to show you guys this
we'll talk about media manipulation a
lot of people like talking about how cnn
and msnbc all the ratings are in the
gutter they couldn't even break a
million their key demo viewership is
like eighty thousand to a hundred
thousand then i get people mentioning
being like oh tim you get way more views
and and we're sitting here like man our
viewership in the key demo is way higher
than msnbc but it's not about msnbc it's
about how they're getting on social
media let me let me ask you know it's
really it's really interesting we're
talking about this manipulation stuff
how it is that someone like vosh
who is a 20 i think he's 26 he's a
socialist and he's pro-biden i'm like
how does that happen how does a young
edgy upstart socialist come to support
the crony capitalist corrupt candidate
of the establishment party
let me show you this thing on reddit
right here and we'll see if i can
actually you can sort of see the image
maybe i can um okay i can't get the
image this is r
political humor political humor they say
it's got 1.429 million readers i go on
reddit all the time and when you're on
reddit you'll typically see these memes
from political humor now is it sane
rational and honest humor no it's
manipulation how do i know their image
on political humor
is a man you can't really see it on the
camera sorry i can't show it to you guys
you can sort of see it there's a mother
a daughter and a son and they're all
looking at an open door as a man is
walking up the sidewalk to the house
like coming home from work
the family members are all holding
knives as the dad is walking up coming
home from works wiping the sweat off his
brow
on the man walking in it says joe biden
on the family members holding knives
hiding it says military industrial
complex and mainstream media
as if to imply the mainstream media and
the military-industrial complex don't
like joe biden and are waiting to
surprise attack him
the narrative that you get when you go
on these big tech platforms these social
media platforms is that joe biden is
being unfairly smeared what what did we
hear recently i remember who said it
they were like the big difference
between joe biden and donald trump is
that biden doesn't have a main a media
apparatus willing to defend him at all
costs like trump did
gaslighting like who in their right mind
who remembered anything about this is
like yes the media loved trump they were
praising him nonstop
i remember biden being the worst
candidate in 2008 absolute most boring
like what is this old piece of trash
doing on stage why is he who is he first
of all and why is he up there he's
terrible annoying and then obama
appointed him i'm like what the heck the
worst choice on the stage and obama
stuck him in and now that nobody is
president how quickly people i mean if
you don't remember watching 2008 cnn
debates of biden being a just a but
old-school war hawk on stage i mean
disgust sorry tim what were you gonna
say no you're right you're right i don't
want to drop you off you're right in 10
years how much things can change is just
shocking to me but what you need to
understand is
the 10 year old in 2008 was not watching
that debate
and they voted for biden this time
around
i didn't that's what happened i missed
his 1988 plagiarism debacle i don't know
where you guys do you guys vividly
remember where he
lifted whole parts of a uk labor
leader's life and assumed it as his own
is joe biden is that his actual name is
he really named joe biden i don't know
his name is joe bob jr you know that he
i'm not kidding well i don't know so he
took him he took
he took a look uk
robinette biden
[Laughter]
this guy in 1988 basically had to dip
out of the presidential election it
resigned from the election process or
whatever and then
uh what people he stepped out of the
limelight for a decade people forgot who
he was and then
he was still a senator he was like i
never even heard his name from night
between 88 and 2006 did you guys yeah
wasn't he the guy who looked at clarence
thomas and accused him of being a rapist
or something like that i felt right i
wasn't sad
joe biden said that he was number one in
his college class no he was like in the
bottom third i mean he lifted like as i
mentioned whole sections of some uk
labor leader's life i mean yeah joe
biden has been like he has been a
fantastical liar his and now he says
he's like he's against the iraq war but
he voted for the iraq war i mean he's
just lies almost about ever there was
something that he was lying oh oh about
going to um
uh
the the the place in in western
pennsylvania the um
oh yeah i remember i can't remember the
name but i remember in squirrel hell
it's right in squirrel hell i can't was
it like a synagogue yeah it's a
synagogue scrub my god the tree of life
the tree of life uh the tree of life he
said he was there he wasn't even there
so he just lies about everything but
this is a thing today when you have
you don't need a candidate when you have
the media
when they're all lining up to say
whatever they need to say and suppress
what needs to be suppressed as long as
you have that joe biden can call lid go
in his basement and go to sleep that's
what he did
isn't it amazing that the i love the
atlantic article stay stay alive joe
biden all we need is your corporeal form
they just needed a name you know why
obama chose uh uh biden some probably
told him to apparently what they were
saying was that there was concerns that
voters would be worried you know the
first black president wouldn't win so
they said you take an old white man and
put him as the vp and then racist
americans would vote for it that's
that's a lot of the rhetoric i remember
hearing back in the day
so
is this at all surprising though i mean
you had what eight years ago somebody at
yale saying
what college was it they said there was
a clan meeting and it was like a white
sheet covering like a projector or
something like that okay oh yeah that's
right oh my gosh i forgot about it no no
it was like they looked through a window
yeah yeah and they saw like a sheet over
something and they said there was a clan
meeting and then like turns out someone
just draped a sheet over a project
these people are insane and then a
reality
reality show talk a reality show host
gets elected president and then a whole
country allows itself to be shut down
for a spicy flu
and there's still
people out there who
think that
it's killing there are surveys taken all
the time that are like how many people
have done how many people do you think
uh percentage people do you think have
died in this area oh at least 20 percent
there's there's a poll that came out the
other day that said like ten percent or
something i don't know
the numbers
of course you can get a corpse elected
10 of democrats believe that like
something like or wait no no 35 percent
of democrats believe that 10 like the
the 10 percent of people die with with
covet so this is
this is this is what happens when you
have people who
blindly believe whatever the media tells
them and i'm wondering what happened
because i know people who didn't used to
they they used to have critical thinking
abilities
you know friends of mine
gone all of a sudden it's like they turn
on cnn and they're like joe roganate
livestock medicine they go wow
why would he do that critical idiot
critical thinking is critical thinking
in today's day and age is something that
is that is going by the wayside uh
pretty fast uh liberalism was all about
back in the day in the in the wake of
the vietnam war if if the government
told you to eat white bread you were
eating wheat bread didn't matter
liberalism was about tolerance it was
about free thinking it was about
critical thinking
but the modern day left has sort of
shifted from
you know critical thinking free
tolerance to
almost a strict adherence to believing
everything that the government says even
when it contradicts it
like you see this in reporters and i
learned this during my first uh
congressional run
where
where we would be asking questions that
i think perfectly legitimate questions
about the election these questions were
important because
it should we should all aspire to make
our elections better every cycle and the
only way that you do that is by asking
important questions and hope that we can
all work together to make things better
but what would happen is the governor
would release a statement in response to
us with no empirical evidence backing it
up and it would just be like oh you guys
are screwed up you know what you're
talking about and then the media would
regurgitate those very same talking
points so uh these are conspiracy
theorists so they're not even they're
not like
their job is to speak truth to power yet
what they do is just regurgitate talking
from the authority we have good news on
this front though let's talk about what
happened with joe rogan because this is
where this is where they made a big
mistake with joe
you can't go to the biggest podcaster in
the world who has more ratings than you
do and accuse him of doing something he
didn't do and makes no sense so now we
have the story joe rogan considers suing
cnn over claims he used livestock drug
against covin they're making ish up
rogan said i literally got it from a
doctor joe rogan gets sick he comes down
he says hey guys i had covid you know uh
tested positive the doctor prescribed
monoclonal antibodies zpac prednisone
ivermectin and he says within a couple
days he was feeling great that's a
doctor's prescription now i will i will
always state
the cdc says doctors shouldn't prescribe
it it is not authorized or approved by
the fda but that's between joe and his
doctor and i'm like okay if this doctor
prescribed it i'm not a doctor you talk
to your doctor don't talk to me what
does cnn do what did every outlet do
instead of saying that a doctor
prescribed it and you went to walgreens
or whatever to pick it up they said it
was livestock medicine so i don't know
if joe's actually considering suing but
what he said was
you know do i have to sue cnn when he
brought this up and i immediately
thought i was like you know i is cnn's
got to be more careful in that right
nope i want to play for you this clip i
want you to actually hear what cnn said
and hopefully this plays well but let's
let's play it
okay it's not playing at all i think
it's because why is it gonna unmute the
tab that's right i gotta unmute cnn
surprise surprise i have cnn muted all
right let's try this again
okay it's still not making any sound
oh it didn't it didn't work why didn't
it work what the heck there you go okay
that's weird all right we're going to
try this again and we're going to play
one of the world's highest paid and most
influential podcast hosts joe rogan just
announcing that he's tested positive for
coronavirus
rogan telling his 13 million instagram
followers that he was treated with
several drugs and he included ivermectin
on the list a drug used for livestock
the fda and the cdc warn against using
to treat covet
on the chiron while she's saying this it
says joe rogan says he has covid taking
livestock drug despite warnings well
that's the mistake you can use
ivermectin for livestock but livestock
is not a or iron mechanism is not a live
structure that's right right right but
let's talk about the manipulation of the
media in this regard it's so brazen i
think this is actually great news for
everybody for one i think joe rogan
should sue them
and every single outlet that said this
because think about how insane it would
be if you went to the doctor and and
people corrected me the other day so
i'll be more careful on this one you go
to the doctor and he prescribes you
ibuprofen are we going to call that dog
medicine now some people pointed out
dogs can't have a lot of ibuprofen
i looked at no no they're the dogs can
in very small doses but they typically
would give them aspirin in small doses
so let's just say this
they do give aspirin to dogs am i going
to claim that aaron burnett uh
was was seen ingesting dog medicine that
she went to a local store in new york
purchasing dog medicine and then
ingesting it shock in a shockingly
insane move no that's insane that's a
that's a lie
so joe rogan is a guy who goes to his
doctor and his doctor's like here's what
i want you to do and she says oh joe
says okay i guess
and now they're claiming he's taking
livestock drug
that is so overt and over the top this
is going to wake people up they're going
to start asking questions about this
because there's no way i mean there's
gonna be a lot of bad faith people who
are like dudes for horses
it's it's it's it's not there are horse
versions of it
there's me a lot of regular people who
are like what well why would joe i love
joe we're gonna watch him on netflix
well i think
the one thing that rogan said in that
first 14 minutes with segura was he said
he explained he said they couldn't get
the vaccine through
they couldn't get the vaccine through
the emergency um
authorization use unless there was no
other
there was no other treatment but that's
but that and you know like when i got it
i took ivermectin
i
towards the end of it i just
there was some other stuff that
another one that trump had mentioned
last year that got demonized and that
knocked it out of my system completely
and i was fine four days later but
the challenge with this stuff is there's
no control when people just decide to
self-medicate or whatever and i suppose
the challenge is that's consent i mean
that's what that's consent that's
personal consent that's me doing what i
want to do it's me doing what i want to
my body the the left complains oh the
reason
everything is so expensive in healthcare
in this country is because it's a free
market
it's a free market really i i can't
order medication that i want i can't say
oh i want to treat myself with this i
should be able to put anything into this
stupid thing right here that i want to
very very libertarian argument it is a
little sorry argument but
imagine if it was a friend
so hold on i got to address this all
right
do your thing so so
what i would say is
always go to your doctor i'm not going
to question someone's doctor giving them
giving a prescription when it comes to
joe rogan
they're highlighting the livestock the
ivormectin and the problem with that is
he also got monoclonal antibodies which
is uh does does have emergency use
authorization which completely in my
opinion debunks the argument made by joe
and the one you just made if the concern
was really that if they authorize
ivermectin then the vaccines lose eua
that would make no sense for regeneron's
monoclonal antibodies if they really
thought that there was an effect that
ivermectin was effective they could just
do an eu waa and retain the emergency
authorization for any other treatment
they've already given an eua to as well
plus community has already been approved
and so i guess the argument they're
saying is until until it hits market as
a brand the euas will remain i don't
think modern and johnson johnson will
just lose their emergencies
authorization because something got
approved so that doesn't make sense you
i suppose you could argue profit motive
but then you're starting to get into you
know
i don't know it starts making more and
more assumptions it could just be that
there was a meta-analysis of 14 studies
showing that ivor macden was
inconclusive there's also a
meta-analysis of 53 studies saying that
it was uh showing that it um
i forgot the word is but long story
short that it inhibited ivermectin so if
these both inhibited covalent
i'm sorry yeah yeah inhibited covet
sorry uh i guess so my conclusion
ultimately is if there's insufficient
data or if there's conflicting data then
perhaps the the answer is simply the cdc
doesn't want people recommending
something they're unsure about because
it might not actually do anything there
might be some people saying like wow it
really worked for me yeah well joe rogan
also got monoclonal antibodies so we we
can't say definitively because there's
no control so when you when you have
someone who who gets sick and then says
i went and took x medication or whatever
it's like yeah well we need a control to
figure out whether or not that was
actually you ingesting something or if
you just beat it so ultimately i'll just
put it this way i think people are
making a huge mistake ingesting horse
medicine in any amount so that's the big
story people like i'll tell you this the
horse paste the the horse ivermectin
sold out in a lot of places that to me i
think is is absolutely insane simply
because
there are there is human grade and
there's animal grade we mentioned this
the other day but i can't ignore
breaking down the points otherwise
people get mad in super chat when when
the when the years when the us
government is regulating something and
it sounds like you're going to be less
of a big fan of a lot of a lot of the
regulations but when they're like okay
we're going to approve something they'll
say hey we can't put this much lead in
it because human livers can't handle
that and it'll make them really sick
so this cannot be approved in this
formulation but for a horse they might
be like oh horse kitties are fantastic
we don't got to worry about that
appearing in it so what happens is
animal grade stuff is very very
different the example i give is that
cats can drink salt water humans can't
we wouldn't simply look at a cat
drinking salt water and be like i can
drink it too so i think people are
making a huge mistake that being said
these news stories about you know the
hospitals being over overflow flooded
and everything are completely bs it was
a huge hoax
ultimately i just say
you know i'm i i think people can do
what they want to do i suppose uh but
when it comes to any medical decisions i
think it's got to come from someone who
actually knows what they're talking
about otherwise you fall victim to
manipulations conspiracies and if if if
you're willing to go to tractor supply
for stuff because you read something on
the internet
and you haven't found a good doctor even
a trump supporting doctor a hardcore
trump supporting doctor who who wrote
all these news stories like yo people
can trick you into doing really dumb
things and i think it's not a good idea
to go yeah but here's the thing you can
go into mexi in mexico you can walk into
any pharmacy and say give me ivermectin
give me a give me hydroxyl chloroquine
and you can treat yourself
if people were doing that in mexico
which i assume they are and they were
dropping dead from this i think we'd be
hearing about that all over the media
yeah i i think it ultimately just comes
down to uh
well for one do you trust the media do
you trust the mexican media and i don't
think the issue is death the cdc says
the issue is potential side effects and
the bigger issue like i mentioned is
if there's monoclonal antibodies which
the fda says is authorized it works joe
hogan took that got better and there's
vaccines which they say you know if you
look at israel and some of these other
countries the efficacy has been dropping
and advocating for booster shots so that
becomes a big challenge but ultimately
do we say hey look at we have a big
chunk of studies that say it's good and
a big chunk of studies saying we're not
sure it's inconclusive do we advocate
for something we're unsure about
what if what if people then say i'll do
that instead and then it doesn't work
and things get worse i'm not advocating
for it either way i'm just saying that i
did i did this and i did that and it
wasn't from a tractor supply store and
well that's that i'm talking about
people
like literally you go to the local
tractor supply there's none left and
they have a big sign saying don't eat it
and i agree you shouldn't i just put it
this way
you can't get medical advice from us
no one here is a doctor who knows
we're not also not doing research on
this stuff that's why you got to find
out who you trust from medical
professionals and talk to them i i i
have one thing to add to this is is what
makes me uncomfortable right
uh this is a once in a hundred year
you know pandemic right um
this we're still in it's in the infancy
of researching
covid19 and effective therapeutics and
vaccines and you know now you need one
two three boosters
why
then
while we are trying to explore
scientifically right in embracing the
scientific method with regards to
finding an effective vaccine in
therapeutics why then are we
censoring discourse
that doesn't fit the media narrative
right well we're talking about median
errors it's like you're seeing you know
youtube channels or or
censored of actual doctors
board certified doctors virologists
epidemiologists they're getting censored
because they're not saying the right
stuff but these are doctors and it's not
like they're they're coming at these
positions from like left field these are
clearly not conspiracy theories
yet they're being censored and i think
what what happens when you do that
is it crea it creates a sense of unease
in people
and and it makes people think that the
information that they're getting might
not be trustworthy because
some
some points are okay to make some are
not now clearly they're it's the advice
that's the problem it's when the doctors
like you know brett weinstein did his
podcast the reason he got a strike was
because they were advising people to
take action
that like when when joe rogan went on a
show this is one of the first
controversies when uh he said you know
he would advise young people not to get
the vaccine i'm like i don't think joe
should be giving people advice on what
they should do with you know medical
treatments we had candace owens on and
she said he's entitled to his opinion i
said that's true he should be able to
give his opinion
and so
well having an opinion and saying your
opinion are different things he should
be able to have an opinion whether or
not he expresses it it's up to the terms
of service of the the issue was
directly saying you advise people to do
something if joe said i don't think x
should happen
i think that'd be a little bit different
from telling people so so i'll tell you
this it's funny when you see people say
i am not a financial advisor i am not a
lawyer i am not giving legal advice we
hear that all the time the same thing is
true for medical advice i i don't like
the idea of like armchair medical
therapy stuff because like
here's my issue
i don't think just because i distrust
the media i should go ahead and just
trust someone else outright
and when i look at the fda's website and
again i i don't necessarily inherently
trust the government i think there's
revolving door policies we've got people
from big pharma they're revolving door
into government stuff there's reason
always be skeptical but at the same time
when i when i when i read things in the
mainstream media that are out like
outright fabrications and then i go to
the cdc website the cdc says something
substantially more honest i say
substantially because it's ultimately
down to who you trust but
you go to uh the fda or the cdc what
does the fda say about the pfizer
vaccine community they have they have a
whole insert saying there's insufficient
data on pregnancies and there's no
long-term effects because it's now
entering long-term long-term trials the
fda literally says that they're not
hiding it from you you go to the media
and they'll tell you it's not true
they'll be like no no it was all done
it's like why are you the fda doesn't
say that i can go to their websites and
that was that was something that i think
was kind of big for me when
when i was looking up the appropriate
actions what do that what does youtube
say to do
that people should you should be not
advising medical uh treatments people
should be going to their medical
professionals
a lot of people say like oh but tim all
doctors are dumb and i'm like yo what if
you have a trump supporting doctor like
conservative doctors exist right you
don't think they're dumb i guess well
one one way you phrased earlier is talk
to someone that knows what they're
talking about i.e a doctor but the
problem is doctors don't know everything
and sometimes they learn only a specific
amount of information they know it
really well but they don't know and that
doesn't change the argument it doesn't
change go to a doctor like i have no
idea what this is like why are you going
to him it's like like i always say you
don't go to carpenter to fix your toilet
that's why you should
consider going to lots of different
doctors is my point i guess because
every doctor is going to know a
different amount of information about
different kinds i i think
i think youtube is scared of liability
i think they're terrified of it i think
when people say go out and say i'm not a
financial advisor they're they're
worried about liability i mean that's
why we say because we don't want people
to be like oh they advised me to do
something you got sick like if we come
out we told people to take some kind of
medical action and then they went and
did and got sick and died we'd be on the
hook for millions of dollars no no we
don't give medical advice i understand
that youtube's scared of liability i
think ultimately it comes down to the
bottom dollar talking like another
example of how this functions is we're
talking with uh chloe valderry she does
the theory of enchantment it's like
anti-racism training that's like opposed
to wokeness and critical race theory she
was saying the reason these institutions
are implementing this critical race
theory stuff is not because they believe
it it's because they're scared of
liability
they're they're they're worried about
getting sued ever so they're just like
bring the people and let them say
whatever they want
i think that's a big driving force in
this obviously big pharma wants to make
a lot of money they get guaranteed no
liability contracts with all the
vaccines and because of that
it shows distrust so ultimately i'm like
this
just because a big pharma is getting a
contract doesn't mean you should just
trust the other person saying something
wildly different that's why i'm like
dude don't let the culture war influence
your medicine like obviously do your
research
but you got to find someone who's
convincing like who's going to be like
let me show you the literature let me
break it down for you let me take those
partisans out of the picture and make
sure i'm giving you good medical
information when you get people that
abuse the literature like cnn just did
with this
thing
yeah saying that that's it's what do
they say exactly what's the thing the
ticker the words that came up taking
livestock drug despite warnings that is
misinformation it's not livestock drug
and they deserve to be sued i i don't
want to say he should because it's not
me doing it it's a big process to do it
but if he sues them
this is this becomes a nexus point of
whether or not this stuff is is animal
feed livestock medicine isn't there
isn't there a part of this i mean
everything i mean you're you're i agree
with everything that you're saying but
like when when president trump
uh talked about
the potential of
hydroxychloroquine right right is that
what it is hydroxychloroquine it was a
z-pack yeah the combo z-pipe it felt
like the media just opposed it because
trump said it and there was no critical
thinking to go behind it like no
assumption that hey this is the
president of the united states like he
might be privy to medical information
that maybe at least in early stages that
we don't have but then after trump is
not president anymore there's what
studies that have come out that say hey
maybe hydroxychloroquine is is well that
well so effect some somewhat effective
they were doing studies the whole time
and there was a promising study out of
france it's why trump mentioned it and
here's what happened trump would read
something in the news
say it and then immediately the news
would flip on the whole thing so it was
crunch right tech crunch reported
that the combination it was zinc and uh
uh azithromycin and hydroxychloroquine
was promising
not a promising is a long way to go
before it's before determining efficacy
and truth so trump was like it looks
very good we'll see and then immediately
they're like trump is pushing conspiracy
right and people are eating fish
medicine and all the other nonsense
you know i will tell you it is true
there have been anecdotes about people
who buy the horse pays protective supply
eat the whole thing
and i'm like we get people saying like
well you're not supposed to eat the
whole you're not supposed to eat it it
says on it you can't even give it to a
horse intended for human consumption i
didn't know horse was like a commonly
eaten thing but it even says it's funny
when it says it says uh do not give to
horses meant for human consumption is
what it says on the box but what it
means is do not feed the horses that are
meant for human consumption and it says
not do not feed the horses period meant
for human consumption you see see how i
could mix that up right are they telling
me it's meant for human what does this
say
no no don't feed it to horses that
you're gonna eat if you're gonna eat
exactly exactly exactly so uh
anyway the point is
when uh right now reuters
it has been reported actually a couple
months ago reuters reported that oxford
is doing a study on ivermectin which is
promising
and so i'm just like
can we can we just chill you know do we
do we say like okay this is really great
oxford this is fantastic we got a bunch
of other studies there's data coming out
of other countries can we have a serious
conversation about this well the media
lies so that makes it impossible youtube
is paranoid and terrified of uh uh
liability liability issues so they go
nuts on it and then my ultimate thing is
like bro i don't think we should be
giving people advice on what they should
be ingesting anyway i think their doctor
should be doing that so if that if
that's the way to just be like
we don't give financial advice we don't
give legal advice we don't give medical
advice all right well there we go i'm
not even advising people to get the
vaccine because that's the same thing
that's another big complaint i had when
casey neistat told me on twitter that he
pulls into a parking lot waited for 45
minutes and stuck his arm out the window
to get a shot and i was like bro did you
talk to your doctor
and they got mad at me i get all these
leftists mad at me for saying talk to
your doctor about getting the vaccine
because we don't want adverse reactions
we don't want to hear these stories
about people anaphylaxis there was early
on nurses had anaphylactic shock from
this and then they were like okay maybe
you shouldn't get the second dose i'm
like what's a good idea for people to go
to their doctor before getting medicated
but what you get now from the mainstream
left and this is what youtube allows
youtube will definitely allow you to
give medical advice so long as you're
telling people to get vaccinated without
going to their doctors which is insane
oh that they i don't know but this that
you're this is my whole point this is
the point that i was trying to make
so the liability argument is perhaps a
compelling one and one that i i could be
swayed but
the point that i was making to you is
that some opinions are okay right some
are not and that right there like you
can get banned for saying something that
is counter to the media narrative like
you said like you said you could go on
youtube right now and and advocate for
people to get to get vaccinated right
without consulting their doctor um
that's okay you don't get centered for
that but any discussion of you know
promising medicine that is not approved
you get centered what that does from uh
from a societal standpoint is create a
divide and it sows distrust well that's
that's the more discourse that's better
right that is the liability the reason
so so here's the important point in the
rules it specifically says
that you can't say there's a cure you
can't advocate for treatments and you
must tell people to go and talk to it
and say you must but it's like you can't
discourage people from seeking out
medical professionals or something like
that
the issue is
ivermectin uh a hydroxyl chloroquine
zpac are not authorized by the fda for
use in treating this because of that you
can't tell people to do it you know what
else is a huge problem with this is is
the
our institute nobody trusts our
institutions anymore
and they have become everything's
political everything is political and
and and in fact that is a a goal of the
radical left is to sort of penetrate
institutions
and as a way to exercise some sort of
control over people and now nobody
trusts institutions anymore you can run
for your county treasurer and somebody's
going to ask you what your opinion on
abortion right that's where we're at now
that's that's true that's true but this
is the problem i have with the whole
with with a lot of the debates over a
lot of things and that's why people are
like tim's a milk toast fence it i'm
like dude i'm not just going to say i
trust one faction over the other because
i don't trust one faction you know what
i mean like trust is earned so when it
comes to any kind of scientific research
i'm like i look at this and just say i
got to make sure i'm not getting my
information from culture war sources on
this one you know
if i go to my doctor and i say here's a
story what do you think and he doesn't
know about it i'll find a better doctor
if i'm like hey here have you heard of
brett weinstein's podcast what do you
think and if he's like i'm not sure i'll
bet okay maybe i need someone who's been
following all of this debate in this
news there was a guy who was in the you
guys know the frontline doctors
coalition or whatever yeah apparently
there's a guy who like defected i don't
know if that's the right word but he's
been critical and he was speaking with
this progressive on youtube how
you know he's critical of the media the
media lies saying a lot of the same
things i'm saying and he was also adding
that it seems like some of these guys
who are advocating for ivermectin it's
become overtly political for them where
they're so angry at the media for lying
about horse dewormer and livestock that
now they just assume anybody who
challenges the idea is pushing some kind
of narrative when in reality
there are studies that are promising and
there are studies that are saying
nothing that there was no impact or that
it would ultimately didn't help at all
and so we're investigating trying to
figure out if it works but it's breeding
zealots the the there's it's the counter
identity right
we talked about this again with chloe
that some people are have counter
dependent identities where their
identity is based upon hating the other
group and that's why i'm like look man
you can believe that the right tends to
be more honest in their media and the
establishment left is lying nonstop
that's true that doesn't mean you can
just assume certain science is or isn't
correct without going through it and it
also means for someone like me i'm like
when i had when i had chris martenson
here and he was like look at the studies
that say this i google search the
opposite and found studies that said the
opposite and i'm like what should i what
should i blindly trust you when i can
find a bunch of other studies saying
something else and then am i supposed to
assume all those other studies are
conspiracies i can't do that i literally
can't
throw my hands up go to a doctor man i
have no idea
that simple
were there studies when you were looking
through them that you said there were a
lot of positive studies that showed
promising effectivity and then a lot of
studies that were they didn't know were
there studies that said it didn't work
yes
when i say inconclusive or didn't know
is like they were literally saying we
saw no change at all interesting not no
impact whatsoever well to me that breeds
at least the the need for new studies if
there's a bunch of studies that okay
that's good yeah i mean the oxford one
that came out a couple months ago so the
problem so i will say this
this this this discussion is is a hot
topic for sure people are probably super
chatting right now saying tim you're
wrong for whatever it's like okay i'm
fine i'm fine with being wrong i'm not a
doctor i can't i can't tell you what for
what i can tell you is isn't this proof
the media lies well what's happening is
this the administrative deep state like
these people that aren't elected but
like the head of the cia the people that
are appointed and that have these long
careers are they feeding information to
the media and they're telling the media
projects
it starts with the administration the
deep state no no i'm sorry they feed
information wait wait let me finish this
first and then disagree with you i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm stopping
you right now why what part you have
jumped the shark no i'm wondering
how so
is the deep state cia feeding
information the administrative state the
people that are appointed not not
elected the people that are being
appointed that have these long careers
that don't they're not getting voted out
basically what does the cia have to do
with what's happening whoever the head
of this year is a point like a
mockingbird argument he's the head of
ci's appointed he's not we don't vote
for him and so there's all these
organizations with these appointees they
call it the administrative state
are those people speaking news nothing
to do with where's the media getting
it's it's parroting point that they're
all repeating it's it's coming in
to war
cnn msnbc definitely appoint former
spooks and and government agents to talk
about why war is good and why trump was
bad and then trump was also good when he
bombed stuff when big pharma buys
advertisements and then also people are
scared to criticize them or when youtube
is scared of liability or when you have
this dominant dogmatic tribal cult that
just agrees with itself as long as in
opposition to the other because they're
counter dependent ideologies that is
just a very simple phenomenon we've been
experiencing so you think it'll come out
and just be like the government
conspiracy is feeding livestock i
wouldn't say it is i'm asking is this is
this possible like so you're saying it's
more of an emergent thing where there's
people that have money invested the
media doesn't want to lose that money
the the people in the media are actually
psychotic and they believe this refuse
so there's that reason
do you think that's more likely than
that there's an organization that's kind
of controlling it donald trump came out
and said hey this study out of france is
promising and the media immediately went
insane screaming trump was a nazi and
pushing conspiracies
so then you get all of these tribalists
being like well the media said it now
because they hate trump they've been
trying to find a replacement for trump
since trump left marjorie taylor greene
lauren bober tucker carlson it doesn't
work trump is trump nobody else is trump
but you have
an entire group of of 70 or i think it's
unfair to say 70 million people but the
democratic voter base that for some
reason believes the economy is good
right now when we just we have
even higher record job openings number
we have seven million people losing
their benefits we have an eviction
moratorium ending yet when you ask
democrat voters the economy they say yes
those people are insane
and and and they believe and and here's
the issue
people talk about red pill blue pill the
red pill people are woken up the people
who are who are who are living in the
matrix
are writing the news and writing public
policy they're not just sitting back
believing lies from some grand overseer
who's trickling down fake news from the
deep state these people genuinely eat
their own refuse and then spit it back
out in new york times and then other
people here and they believe it again
the best example i i think is jack
dorsey himself
used to be the free speech wing of the
free speech party then twitter became an
algorithmic nightmare where people were
screaming at their lungs because rage
generates retweets
all of a sudden within a decade joe a
jack dorsey is now ultra woke believing
this insane refuse his own his own
system fed back to him they have no
ability to raise their head above the
clouds and take a look around and see
what's happening they're stuck in a mess
of their own making some people know
it's a lie and they grift a lot of
people will read cnn and say wow it's
true joe rogan took livestock medicine
and then they'll go on just believing
it's all a fact spreading it all to
their friends and they're adamant that
they know the facts then they come to
you and say wow economy is doing pretty
well isn't it and you're like uh 7.5
million people just lost their benefits
the eviction moratorium has ended that
certainly is not indicative of a good
economy is it
10.9 million job openings we only filled
235 000 jobs the past month when we
already had record openings and you can
google search closed comma shortage
and see all the businesses all the
government institutions that are
collapsing as we speak
and these people believe the economy is
good i'm sorry we got a large faction
tens of millions of people who have lost
their minds in this country who will sit
here and tell you you're in the cult
you're the evil trump cultist conspiracy
theorist simply because you google
search things instead of just believing
cnn
man i got that
well right that's good good good show
everybody good show everybody
yeah let me let me uh let me pull this
up let's let's get into this how about
how about we do this
u.s job opening surpassed 10.9 million
the number of open jobs in america is
greater than the number of unemployed
people and that's two months in a row
now now last month they filled close to
a million jobs but at 10.1 million
openings that was a record and that
meant there were more openings than
people available to work
sit from april to july
we lost 3 million jobs per month about
just shy of 3 million but only gained
about a couple hundred thousand per
month so it was like for every three
jobs lost one job has been gained
the economy is not doing well
you look at all the shortages all the
shutdown
and there's still people in this country
who are like yeah joe biden the economy
is doing pretty good
and i have no idea how that's possible
but i'll tell you this
if these people
at cnn and msnbc continue to push this
stuff
they are they're the people who are
stripping the copper out of the walls of
the building we're in to go sell for
scrap they're the people who saw the
iceberg that saw the titanic hit the
iceberg now they're stealing all the
fine china and silverware and rushing
the lifeboats
they're extracting everything while the
ship is sinking it's why rachel meadow
she went from a daily show now she's
doing a weekly show a lot of people have
pointed out yeah she's jumping [ __ ] she
doesn't want to be left holding the bag
so she's reducing her workload taking a
bigger paycheck
i can't remember who told us it might
have been bannon that jon stewart
shut his show down just before trump
came in because they all knew it was
going to happen and nobody wanted to be
doing a nightly show where they're
forced to lie
so they cancel it and that's basically i
think what we're going through right now
is like you take a look at you know
someone like ian who by any any sane
metric a conservative would call a
leftist a liberal or you know at the
very least on the left
yet people in media would say ian's far
right
it's because i have long hair
i think that's a reason to make you far
left people look at me and they make
assumptions yeah yeah
well we're trapped in this
you know so i think ultimately what this
what this brings us to is we're watching
the country collapse it's breaking apart
portland announces they're banning trade
with texas california says no travel to
other states i'm like yo at this point
this is one by one the bricks falling
out of the building as the united states
is crumbling down
and so long i think i think the main
issue is
you've got people on the left who
actively want that to happen the occupy
wall street people for instance were
like very much so wanting the us to
collapse antifa very clearly wants the
us to collapse the they they all
basically think this country is racist
6019 project all that stuff and one by
one our institutions are failing it's no
surprise the people in government are
incentivized to extract as much as they
can as the ship is falling apart and
what's what's the end result i guess we
break apart
that's what
should have happened a long time ago
i mean how do you
you have people who are like okay i
literally want to be able to have a baby
be born
and punch a hole in its head and suck
its brain out
that was in virginia yeah they literally
want that to happen how am i supposed to
share air with them how am i supposed to
share a polity with them
i mean
why should i be why should i be forced
to
why don't we just break up and the
hardest part is you have
states where a state like texas okay
you have the dallas fort worth area
dallas is insanely left
fort worth is right
so how do you do that
you have to come up we have to come up
with a way that people can be able to
choose the kind of governance they want
because we're just going to be at war to
the point where
oh i don't know people are burning
cities down i mean i i mean if if
i i think you know maybe if this
continues you might see uh left and
right wing groups fighting in the
streets
or maybe shooting at each shooting at
each other oh wait that's not going to
be in the right wing cities though
that's all going to be in the left those
cities need to be
london i was joking because it already
happened right right this past weekend
in the past weekend there's been
shootouts in portland uh so i i
personally think that that
there needs to be a unifying principle
around which people can gather
in order to have a a strong country
right you you talked i think you were
right that how the modern day right
conservatives for the last 50 years have
ceded the our education system
entertainment and the media to the left
and we're reaping the consequences of
that today right and i think part of
part of that is when you teach kids you
talk about this critical race theory
stuff and
um and and and certainly in college for
a long time it was happening in college
where people
students were being taught
to think this country was a horrible
place an evil place where everyone was
racist
we came up i grew up you know and was
taught you know we judge people by the
content of their character not the color
of their skin like we read martin luther
king we ingested it we believed it and
but today
your child in a public school is being
taught that they're either a victim or a
suppressor based on the color of their
skin they're taught to
hate the other based on the color of
their skin and when that happens i mean
you start to believe in a ways
especially if you're a little one right
that your country is a fundamentally
evil horrible place and and that's why
we have such unbelievable group
polarization in this country because
we've had one political party
who has done nothing but divide us among
age race demographic you know young old
rich poor black white christian atheist
because that's how they maintain power
right i have a different view and you
and i have
talked about this in the show and even
debated about it a little bit but i i
you know maybe it's me being naive but i
believe that what makes america
exceptional is is not necessarily our
diversity now diversity is great like
around this table we have an
unbelievable amount of diversity and
diversity of thought is great because it
challenges us
to to to think in different ways but but
but what makes this country exceptional
is that for
you know 200 years we've put aside our
petty differences or done the best that
we could in order to put us put aside
our differences and united around the
principle of being an american today we
don't have that anymore and you see
little fractures in every aspect of what
we do in our education system even in
sports now are political right i mean
you know how we solve it
sean parnell does not run for senate in
u.s senate he runs for mayor of his
hometown he runs for mayor of his
hometown and he and he
gets people elected to the board who
agree with him and say we're not going
to teach that crap here
the federal gop is controlled opposition
for the regime we know that even kevin
even kevin um
kevin mccarthy the minority leader he
in the house yeah in the house he was oh
so oh i'm a total trumper until january
6 and then he starts backing off and
then he starts going back look at what
desantis is doing in florida look at
what abbott is doing in texas if sean
parnell ran for governor of pennsylvania
and ran on three things you're not
teaching that crap in schools um
if you don't want to mask on your child
you're not going to have a mask and if
you don't want a needle stuck in your
arm you don't have to have a needle
stuck in your arm if you ran for for
governor of pennsylvania on that you
would get elected and you would do more
for the people that you love in your
home state than you would going to
washington dc and getting stuck in that
mess i i don't disagree with what you're
saying
um
i i do think that there are many
positive ways that you especially if
you're getting elected and the idea that
all politics is local right and like
we're seeing just in pennsylvania alone
like an unbelievably intense focus on
school boards
we've never seen anything like the
intensity that's around school board
elections this year but we're seeing
that at every level and mayor governor
there's a gubernatorial election in
pennsylvania in 2022 and i would say 99
of the time i would agree with you
except for 2022
if we lose the state of pennsylvania
which is a republic with this seat
senator toomey's retiring it's an open
seat so there's no incumbent there it's
been in republican control for a while
um if we lose the seat and the democrats
of course know that there's no pathway
to the senate majority without flipping
this seat in pennsylvania they have to
do it if they want an actual majority
then it almost doesn't matter if there's
a republican governor in pennsylvania
because the feds whether it's with hr1
uh the the you know
for the people act or senate bill one
which is basically a nationalization of
our of our elections the feds are taking
away power from the states at a rate
that has
never been seen before
in american history
and
the critical fight for me is is in the
senate to stop the radical left from
packing the supreme court from nuking
the filibuster to making washington dc
and puerto rico a state
it doesn't matter if there's a
republican governor in pennsylvania of
course it does of course it does i'd
rather see a republican there than a
radical leftist but i'm saying
i
i don't want to see
states stripped of of their power and
and the left today will absolutely do
that they're not shy about their agenda
and for me so i see not only is
leadership important less political
party to me and leadership is actually
what really matters
uh but being winning the seat in
pennsylvania defending pennsylvania but
also defending the country against being
a hedge against
just the insane radicalism of the new
democratic party and not allowing them
to fundamentally transform this country
into something that we've never
recognized before i think you actually
you know what you're saying is another
reason
he could win the senate if you campaign
in the same things the state level not
you know the kids your schools school
boards you know vaccine choosing to get
vaccinated or whatever school choice is
something that is unbelievably important
and and so i think covet and these
insane lockdowns have shown us this
something crosses
you know uh
socio-economic strata
it's important in the inner city it's
important in the royal community
especially in pennsylvania where
broadband is a real issue when schools
closed and
we went virtual there were kids in the
inner city that that didn't have a
laptop computer to get on the internet
or didn't have access to the internet
you had kids in rural communities who
were climbing to the tops of their silos
in the hopes that they could get on the
internet and the starbucks across town
because they didn't have broadband
internet they had no internet whatsoever
so you're right there are those very
same issues like i'm vehemently opposed
to vaccine mandates i will say that like
as you as you mentioned if you want the
vaccine consult with your doctor by all
means get the vaccine but let no
government mandate it um i think it's uh
so the government doesn't know
your personal life they don't know your
personal finances
they don't know the struggles you go
through
but and this tends to be
republicans do this like you mentioned
the the federal gop is just opposition
control that position
they they they do these blanket policies
that don't make sense for localities
so they're the one thing i think people
definitely need to pay attention to as
you mentioned school boards are really
important uh they're so important but i
i will say too i think you're correct
they need a better governor in in in
pennsylvania
john would be a great governor but
if sean is going to get that senate seat
and it's going to have a big impact at
the federal level even if the federal
gop is uh controlled opposition i think
that's actually a good argument for why
more
honest
individuals should be running and
displacing th this is why i want
i think desantis has done more
to protect his
constituency than probably any
politician in
my life you're you're 100 you're 100
right and he's doing that at the and
he's doing that at the governor level
while he's being attacked well and he's
just middle finger so this is this is
the point that i wanted to make and i by
the way you're right i think ron
desantis has done an incredible job in
florida
you're right uh all my life i have
wondered why
republicans
haven't fought harder right i think
there's a lot of reasons why i think a
lot of republicans don't want the media
attention they want to fight the media
and the democrats a lot of that
but what trump taught the republican
party and certainly this next wave of
sort of republican blue collar working
the party of the see the republican
party is the party of the working class
individual freedom and liberty small
federal government all all the same
stuff but the but the
trump taught this next generation of
republicans how to fight
and and that the cultural fight is also
important and it cannot simply be
discarded
and
some of us have been trying to teach
libertarians that too
well
well i i so i i do think that that that
we can change the whole uh uniparty
because there are times where i'm so
frustrated
at how the republican party operates but
the only way you change it is to get
involved and and be the change that that
you hope to see
but that that's why it's we can stop
we can stop the insanity you're talking
about the usa and an empire in decline
america in decline or late stage
collapse i don't i don't i don't buy i
don't buy that uh
i think that good strong leadership can
change it but impend if we win
pennsylvania we can stop the insanity of
the radical left that all rests on
pennsylvania i'm telling you that we can
stop them from
doing what they're doing to this country
and that's why pennsylvania is so
important and that's why
that's why the radical left and people
like chuck schumer were running ads
against me two weeks before i was even a
candidate because they know how
important it is
i look at some of this news man and i i
genuinely believe i just had a video
taken off of youtube oh really yeah just
so right now yeah i just got an email oh
wow is it a hard strike or episode i
dropped today
um violates medical misinformation
policy there it is
it's going right i i feel like um
it really is a battle between good and
evil
and i think many of these establishment
cultists think it's a battle of good and
evil too and i think they're wrong about
that because they're in a cult
they they they come on they say oh all
trump supporters are in cults these
people who are you know eating horse
pace they're all they're all insane and
the stories are often fake i mean
they're often fake with the story about
oklahoma being overrun with you know
gunshot victims couldn't get right
totally fake story totally fake story
yeah we have the story from uh uh
tempgates.com about jimmy kimmel
kimmel says unvaccinated americans
taking ivermectin should be left to die
if they get sick actually it's a little
we'll break that apart he actually said
that if someone comes in who's
unvaccinated eating horse goo rest in
peace wheezy
and then he said we still got a lot of
pam dimwits out here people are still
taking this ivermectin this the poison
control centers have seen the spike in
calls from people taking livestock
medicine to fight the coronavirus but
they won't take the vaccine it's like
you're a vegan and you're like no i
don't want a hamburger give me that alpo
instead one of the reasons these sea
biscuits are opting for ivormectin is
because they don't trust big pharma
which is fine i guess except for the
fact that ivankten is made by merck
which is the fourth largest
pharmaceutical company in the world and
even merck is telling people to cut it
out
so i'm not here to get into the medical
debate with jimmy kimmel i'm gonna talk
about the overt callousness
there was another story i saw from this
mainstream journalist who said we need
to stop shaming people who are doing
things we don't like and the reason was
she said
when these stories like with jimmy
kimmel come out when the oklahoma story
comes out her dad turns it off and stops
listening saying this is negative it's
lies manipulation i don't want to hear
it anymore
so they outright don't trust the media
they don't trust big pharma i think it's
a fair point to say
we shouldn't like the fact that he's
like rest in peace wheezy that's insane
that's like a dark thing to say about
someone how about what if he said this
recipes fatty oh what's that you had a
heart attack and you're overweight too
bad no we don't do that we say we're
gonna try and save you when we don't do
this we
we don't do this with the flu
you know yeah people have a choice of
flu shots i understand they're different
this it is it's different but we you
don't shame people for getting
sick
and it's almost like it's it's the
reason why it's so dark is this he's
he's cal he said he's callous about he's
almost wishing for it to happen
and that's just so wrong these people
i'm i'm i'm really angry man i just
gotta say i
the media is the most destructive vile
and disgusting entity in this country
and i mean the corporate press because
when they come out with this stupid
bs about oklahoma call centers and
and cnn says livestock you get people so
distrustful of our institutions they
literally go to tractor supply instead
that's your fault jimmy kimmel that's
your fault aaron burnett if you people
weren't so despicable maybe people might
actually say you know what the vaccine
my doctor says is a good idea instead
now they're like people messaging me
saying don't even trust their own
doctors anymore and i'm like well
look i understand being mad at the
mainstream media and people like jimmy
kimmel being vile disgusting despicable
people
but yo
to then turn around and say i'm going to
distrust all institutions this is the
problem i have i don't blame the regular
working class person i don't blame the
regular person who's confused by this i
blame these vile people like aaron
burnett who come out and say joe rogan's
eating livestock medication which is a
absolute lie i'm almost swearing on this
one because this is why i'm reading this
story i'm reading this quote from jimmy
kimmel and i'm like isn't it crazy that
there are people willing to go to
tractor supply instead of going to a
doctor that's your fault cnn that's your
fault aaron burnett that's your fault
jimmy kimmel is is jimmy kimmel is that
monologue uh is that on youtube right
now oh probably because this is the
point that i was making about so jimmy
kimmel can go on to youtube and advocate
for violence and death against a certain
group of people and that's fine and this
is what breeds the distrust and the
contempt and the anger what about on
twitter you have people saying oh if
people aren't vaccinated and they get
the coronavirus they shouldn't be they
shouldn't be hospitalized so what
they're basically saying is that people
who
decide that they're going to
ignore
ignore what the professionals say and go
out and maybe contract the virus
shouldn't get medical advice
wow i i wonder if somebody would have
said that in the 80s during the hiv
it's just a horrible thing to do or say
about during the aids thing it's just a
horrible thing to do or say about
anybody and you want to be for universal
healthcare and think healthcare is a
human right
tell jimmy kimmel to go shove it because
if you're one of these bernie sanders
supporting progressive socialist and you
think healthcare is a human right it
doesn't matter if you're overweight then
it doesn't matter if you're i don't know
you eat legos are we gonna if some guy
sticks a fork in an outlet don't do that
are we gonna be like no it's his fault
he chose to do it we're gonna be like
this man needs help save him these
people are evil they're evil they're the
ones who go on tv and mock
here's my favorite example
donald trump ordering a well done steak
with ketchup brilliant move trump's a
smart guy legend remember this straight
legend yes yes do you remember this when
donald trump ordered a well-done steak
with ketchup yeah yeah yeah you know why
that was a master a master a master
stroke a genius maneuver
it's 4d chess baby because the media
came out and made fun of him for doing
it they made fun of him for having this
fancy steak well done with ketchup ha ha
what a [ __ ] and then regular people who
aren't wealthy you can't afford filet
mignon said i get my my steaks from the
local supermarket from the save on or
whatever and i put ketchup on it
trump was more relatable one of the
greatest gifts that he gave this country
and i think so many of his policies were
just so good for for the country but but
uh
the fact that he did expose
the media
for who they really were i mean there
was always sort of like a a veneer like
of
maybe maybe not well there's a liberal
by but trump
exposed them for just exactly who they
are and they've never quite recovered
well they've never recovered at all the
media has almost no credibility anymore
you you you were mentioning politicians
getting bullied by the press i mentioned
fauci fauci is talking on some show i
can't remember samantha guthrie or
something and he was asked about well if
one mask works why not two masks and he
says yeah it's just common sense to wear
two masks
and then and then he comes out later on
tv and says no there's no guidance
saying to wear two masks
then the cdc later comes out and says
where are two masks because it is true
also that there are people in government
who are pressured by the media
i don't think there's a grand conspiracy
i certainly think there's interests in
government and corporations that have
influence and affect things what i think
is happening is
we are a country of
i'll be careful we have a lot we are a
country of a large number of cowards
absolute cowards and so that means when
the crackpots say stupid things regular
people say leave me alone i don't want
to get involved we talked about
institutions and not being trusted in
this so did you see the story that broke
today the cdc titan masking guidelines
after threats from teachers union yeah
this this is why everything is political
the radical left has penetrated
institutions to the point where
average people don't trust don't trust
our institutions anymore the system is
for good reason right and so i i think
trump exposed a lot of that and i think
ultimately that
it makes our country in in the long haul
i think it makes our country a better
a better place because the hope is
is that people will start thinking
critically again but we need to start
mitigating the fact that the left
is in charge i mean and i really
honestly believe the only way that you
can do that is to
without bringing secession into it how
about local politics i mean really make
local politics more important like so
gun laws i don't think there should be
any gun laws i think the second
amendment is you know and i agreed yeah
i catch crap for this because i don't
know about constitutional gun laws
according to somebody and um but
so
what did texas just do texas just said
that if a suppressor is made in texas
you can go in and you can buy it without
your 200 nfa tax stamp
well
the reason they can do that is because
they tell the texas rangers they tell
local police that
if the atf comes in don't
don't coordinate with them right don't
give them any cooperation that's what
small towns should be doing yeah and so
a town should be like i mean
the atf then doesn't know who has it and
then and then there's the fact that
my friend michael bolden from the 10th
amendment center looked and said like in
2014
the atf uh the dea did not have the
budget to bust every dispensary in los
angeles county once wow
so they don't have the kind of budget
that we think that they have
so i think local politics is just really
the way forward and i think that's
what's going to br that's what's going
to mitigate all this left
craziness i mean it's you just if you're
in a right town if you're in a town that
leans right
talk about talk to your neighbor about
it i'm moving to a smaller town i got to
talk to neighbors like the second day i
was there and that was better than
anything i had done in atlanta in 15
years
and
you should be organizing and you should
be talking to people about how
talking to the police i mean the problem
with the police i mean i think there's a
big problem with the police in this
country they just have too much to do
there's just too many things for them to
do i mean they should be investigating
crimes i think the numbers are that they
show up to stop a crime uh less than
five percent of the time so they're
basically investigators so
make them investigators make them the
best investigators possible i i think
you're so right about the
the the local politics and it's
something that the left has understood
for a long time now
and they will actually recruit county
commissioner candidates and move them to
states where they think that they can
win
and you have people
like very very wealthy leftists and they
they rolled out their digital
fundraising platform and act blue before
far before conservatives had our own
response and win red there's essentially
the exact same platform except for
there's an algorithm base it's sort of
like the netflix of giving if you like
this guy you might like this guy and as
you get more donors you have a bigger
rolodex you can raise more money and
raise it faster but the left has a big
head start on republicans in that
in that regard um but
the the left has underst has understood
for a very long time
that you've got to organize
all the time you can't stop you can't
just organize for an election and then
everybody goes home and this is
something that i i've been working
really hard at in pennsylvania
is is telling people that hey
we have to organize all this because the
number one thing that i get on campaign
is what what can i do
you know i'm just one person i'm like
well that's enough
like get out there bring people together
and organize and advocate for the things
that you believe in get behind can't it
might not even be me but get behind
candidates that you believe in help them
make phone calls help them knock doors
talk to your neighbors talk to the
police
get involved at the local level organize
24 7 because that's what the left does
and that that's that's that's the
pathway to victory that's how we save
this country there's a dude in new york
he put up a video where he's going
around with these flyers say we do not
discriminate on race creed you know
vaccine are unvaccinated we welcome all
and he says a bunch of stores agreed to
put the signs up and so he just went out
and now all these businesses are saying
like we're not gonna adhere to this
mandate one person one guy and so i'm
like amazing people in new york should
be doing this yeah yeah that was so
great yeah people in new york you should
hear this that's cool yep yep so i
tweeted him out not you know included
his handle i don't have it pulled up
otherwise you know but uh you can go to
my twitter at tim cast and then you can
see the video he made and he's just some
dude he's a big account he's not some
prominent activist he like made the
video he put it up on tiktok and twitter
someone tweeted it i saw it i retweeted
it i told people in new york get active
if you have a problem with what's going
on you can't just sit back and ignore it
that's exactly right that's exactly
right and that's what we've been working
on in pennsylvania and i think it's
working i think i really do think that
2022
i mean first of all we've got to win in
2021 i mean you talked about like
there's not going to be like if you know
the left doesn't fear the an antifa type
response from the right and i think
by and large i think that's a good thing
like the right is like we're law and
order we believe in that and and i think
that's a good thing um but you see it
like we have our judicial races in in
pennsylvania we elect judges in
pennsylvania for some reason i i'm not
sure quite how i feel about that i don't
like that
because there's really no state
contribution limit right so you have
like one super rich billionaire be like
well here's a million bucks go win your
judge race now all of a sudden as if
you're a leftist you you
like almost all leftist judges
uh legislate from the bench they don't
follow the constitution they just
legislate from the bench and so well
anyway we have we have we have we gotta
win these we gotta win in 2021 but i
think we're going to
i think we're going to because we you
know in 2021 we won the ballot
referendums in pennsylvania that that
curb governor wolf's unilateral
authority to declare emergencies because
he just like kept extending covert
emergencies like in perpetuity well we
won that and rep as republicans by 139
000 votes so i think that
people were waking up to this i really
do and you i i'm saying all this to say
it's not just a feeling i see it
empirically as well and i think going
into 2022 with biden is just he just
destroys everything that he touches i
think people
people see it and california will be
interesting whether newsome gets
recalled because you know 538 saying
that he's favored now a bunch of polls
come out saying oh it's over for the
recall effort you know he won
we'll see there was uh there's one dude
colin moriarty posted a photo he got in
virginia of a california recall ballot
huh in virginia what how do you
accidentally mail outside of your state
for your own state's gubernatorial
election
whatever
but um
i think we'll we'll see because i think
a lot of democrats don't like them
there's a lot of democrats in california
probably like another business they're
business owners they're business owners
and they they watch their business
collapse because of ridiculous
government madness i mean i think that
what in california have they even lifted
their lock down yet did they ever
officially lift their lockdown remember
that video of that woman who had a
restaurant and she said outside right
not allowed to have an outdoor seating
area but right next to it is the craft
service yes for a movie production
they're allowed to do this yes it's
insane the rich get richer the
government in the last year
made people close their businesses stay
home and they actually made their loved
ones die alone and people
listened this is a huge problem this is
this is a this is a real if you bring
that up people don't care leftists don't
care
let's face it i mean the left is the one
who has bought into this coveted
religion and they don't care if you
bring that up then you're just well it's
like they were going to die anyway i
mean
and we have another problem in this
country with warehousing our warehousing
are old
you know warehousing our grandparents
instead of having three generation
households like my family does in puerto
rico
it's actually a really interesting point
i i do think that
that the breakdown of the family unit in
in this country and even neighborhoods
like when i grew up uh in in i we had a
neighborhood we would talk to our
neighbors we'd go out and play in the
cul-de-sac
with friends and
i just feel like
that doesn't exist anymore people who
are more insular
then the restrictions in the lockdowns
are a good thing aren't they
what are we seeing more of
the great resignation the job openings
are not due to people
necessarily getting free money a lot of
people have decided with unemployment
they're like why would i look for work
so i think we'll see some we're going to
see a lot of jobs get filled now that
the unemployment benefits are are over
but a lot of people are have been
resigning to 10 million i think 11
million in three months from april to
july
or from april june and why is that
because
they don't want to do these jobs anymore
they've been given a taste of remote
work what does that mean when you work
remote
you see your kids
you wake up you see your kids them off
to school you pick them up you bring
them home you hang out with them i think
a lot of people realize they like doing
that
so now you're hearing a lot of stories
about people saying i don't want to go
back to the office if they don't let me
work remote i'll quit
and so businesses that can have remote
are now are now are doing this take a
look what's happening in schools
parents are getting fed up with schools
well if you work remote you don't need a
babysitter and you don't need your kid
to be in the school you can do a pod
where your you know 10 families put all
their kids together and then hire a
teacher together it's super cheap for
family and then you have one teacher
teaching all these different subjects
that's i think is going to restore a lot
of family and community and whether it's
on purpose or not
i think you're you're you're going to
start seeing a return to a lot of family
values parents teaching their kids
i think i think there's a there's a
light at the end of the tunnel here i
agree i agree if if
gosh there i don't i hate to even speak
about it this way because
but but
people were paying more attention
because of of the pandemic
and the lockdowns or paying more
attention to what their kids are
learning in school and i think that's
why you see just such intense passion
around these school board races because
parents are finally like wait a second
what the heck is this stuff and so
they're involved now they're fired up i
mean every every week we see some like
some viral video of a parent at a school
board meeting telling the board members
what for and getting their mics cut and
stuff so that is certainly a good thing
and and i do think that that teachers
unions now
you know i was just when 9 11 happened
and i joined the military i was an
elementary education major i was trying
to figure out how i was gonna student
teach second grade it's something that
like i i think i have tons of respect
for teachers like you know but
but the teachers unions i think most
people see them today for what they are
and they're putting the bureaucratic
needs of their union before the
educational needs of the student
and i think more people today that the
whole pod concept that you talked about
is is kind of interesting it's
fascinating but school choice is
something that matters to people you
know i think people are going to want to
want their kids to be home whoa
that's crazy yeah
anyway we should go to super chats if
you haven't already smash the like
button go to timcast.com become a member
we're going to have a members only
segment coming up which should be live
around 110 pm and uh like i said smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
smash that like button for ian
i don't hear you
there it is i don't know thanks uh we
got some good ones make 1984 fiction
again says out of curiosity ian how do
you feel about governor northam's
position on abortion keep the baby
comfortable in a bassinet while mom and
doc decide
i have no idea i don't know anything
about it so uh he was doing a radio
interview and he said that when it comes
to abortion
you know
the baby could be delivered
placed aside and then the mother and the
doctor could go into the other room and
make a decision about what to do with
the baby but like a full term baby yeah
like foreign yeah once brain activity
starts to work you're looking at a human
so
that's did you hear what what about the
story i mean
well so let me ask so like if if uh
somebody's you know
you know
35 year old dad walking down the street
slips on a banana peel and hits his head
and then he's in a coma and they're like
we're not getting any brain activity but
he's just in a coma i mean maybe he
could come out of it is he not a human
anymore you just pull the plug well
that's up to the person if they want to
pull the plug at that point but do you
think they should be illegally allowed
to just turn i think they should if
someone is irreconcilable in a coma
according to modern medicine they're
like there's zero hope we have no hope
that they'll ever come out then yeah if
they don't have the right they don't
know that what if they're like we don't
know i so we're not getting any brand
activity i mean it's possible he could
come to and come back
dad i think well i mean i don't know
what the law is but personally i would i
would wait out for hope but i mean if it
was costing me forty thousand dollars a
day maybe like what's money what's more
valuable it's the challenge of saying
that brain activity is the determinate
factor in in life yeah
in baby in a baby formation in a in a
modern human if someone's brain gets
knocked out i mean
they're gone
basically yeah you're they're a husk you
see the challenge there though you're
defining a person based on memories
but what are you other than your pre
your frontal lobe your tim pool your con
yourself you know your ego if that's
stripped from you then what so then the
government should have registered to
trap you around the government
the government oh just to destroy a dead
body no no no like oh if all you are is
your memories and the rest of your body
is
as long as you're alive damage to your
body is is fine right
wait wait uh say that again
if you're defining life as a collection
of memories and brain activity then
why should you have any bodily
government protections
it's still life it's still living like
your muscle is a living muscle it just
doesn't have any human in it like so
it would be okay for a doctor to cut
your arm off
no totally why not
what kind of question is that why would
you ever advocate to have someone cut
your arm off people do it all the time
it's called body dysmorphia yeah that's
it's a dysmorphic behavior it's not real
it's not good no it's bad well so now
you're starting to set arbitrary
morality on when you can and can't
terminate life and what constitutes life
what's i'm not sure i don't i don't
agree with you that it's arbitrary i'm
talking about babies
brain activity and fetuses developing
fetuses as different than someone
falling and hitting their head
so like if a baby is uh a baby is born
and it's not functioning or learning you
think they could so so that's that's
northam's position to be honest northam
was talking about like he's well he says
he's talking about severe abnormality a
baby is born
and then they're like hey wait a minute
this baby's brain's not working
so they could take a fully birthed baby
when the brain isn't working properly
and say
like a brain dead brain dead no the
baby's alive so like autistic or some
some sort of like
limited brain function yeah
i don't think limited brain function
constitutes brain dead
so no that's different to me so like
what if what if the what if the baby has
no functioning brain
other than just like it's breathing
then it's it's it's basically it's not i
mean so you agree with northam's
position yeah if it's like if you have a
brain dead baby coming out of the out of
the woman
and you want to abort that thing then
yeah it's not a human at that point but
it has no brain breathing well if it's
moving around then it has brain activity
i mean it could be it doesn't that's not
necessary it might just be
[Music]
to experience that the issue is the
assumptions made about what northam was
talking about and you can take it two
ways one that he was saying in any
circumstance a baby could be born and
the mother could decide which
technically would be the case or you can
be more generous and say he was
referring to severe abnormality in which
case even in his position
sounds like you would agree
i believe there are no circumstances in
which a baby born that is alive
should be executed with with no brain
like with a computer even with no brain
just like yeah because i i have friends
who who have siblings who are like
severely autistic to the point of like
inability to live
and they love them and they're happy
that they're part of their families and
it's like absolutely
so that that's that's like brain dead
that's another that's another situation
when when a body just lays there with a
pipe down its throat and on a breathing
apparatus i'm not saying that from from
age that's like a brain dead child but
you could you're saying a collection of
your memories in your frontal lobe there
could be no higher function and the body
could still be breathing and functioning
and and i i have i have i have friends
who have family members
who they have feeding tubes
and don't you dare i i dare you go to
them and say they should have executed
that baby i wouldn't never say should
i'm saying you should have the right to
do that yeah
and you'll get punched in the face they
should have the right but there are
certainly families that agree with you
and like i wish this child was never
born it's a burden on my life you know
it's not up to me to decide for someone
else about what to do with their child
or their loved one if something happens
to the brain but i think that if a brain
dead animal lays before you that maybe
we should consider having the right to
destroy that animal for the betterment
of society humans and animals are
different
humans are animals but i think this was
a good conversation so far this is a
good super chat because
it allows us to to talk about the the
deeper uh questions over like what do
you guys think about it
well i mean
i'm pro-life yeah
i'm pro-life and when people start
talking about
whether what decisions should be made i
think about the fact that iceland
doesn't have a down syndrome problem yep
like they don't have a lot of down
syndrome children with down syndrome
yeah because
they
kill them in utero oh my god yeah and
you know what i think i mentioned
the government forces them to do it yeah
and the horses yeah yes it's absolutely
it's government mandated it's horrific
yeah the worst part about it is that one
in five babies who are diagnosed with
down syndrome are not diagnosed
correctly which means that one in five
babies who are aborted in iceland could
be perfectly fine and so therein lies
the problem let's say let's say there's
a baby in the womb and they're like well
we're not detecting brain activity and
then you're like all right terminate and
they were wrong it's the same argument
of the death penalty
that the the the whatever the percentage
is that someone could be innocent i
can't but i believe it is better that
100 guilty persons escape than
ben franklin i agree with that but
brain misdiagnosing autism is different
than misdiagnosing brain dead so i don't
know if that's do people misdiagnose
brain dead the doctors make mistakes all
the time right yeah
and i'm not that's not to say don't
trust your doctor i'm saying well pencil
save you racers and doctors don't rush
to a decision like that yes i just
thought this was a good a good question
because it's not so simple for a lot of
people to just be like a lot of people
take a simplistic view of it like why
would you ever terminate a baby and i'm
like i'm sure there's somebody who's
looking at a baby with such severe
deformities it might only live for a
month
and that's a really difficult question
then right but i think the challenge is
if a woman gives birth to a baby and you
start creating exceptions exemptions for
when you're allowed to literally end the
life of a born baby that's alive it's
like yo you're you're dancing on a
slippery slope right now
and i don't want to start talking about
where that goes because i'll tell you
safe legal and rare 15 years ago turned
into celebrate and your abortion with
that comedian on netflix
yeah shot your abortion let's read some
more though
clarence games says sean parnell are you
going to run for federal senate of pa
since pat toomey isn't running yes i'm
running for it now oh yes i and i need
your help endorsed by trump oh my gosh
yeah how do we not talk about this yeah
just recently endorsed by trump it was
it was amazing but yeah we're we're
gonna win we're gonna we're gonna win
the primary and we're gonna win the
general for sure tyler223 says metallica
shirt he has my vote
you know metallica you know metallica is
underrated and i sort of grew up
listening to metallica underrated black
album
like justice for i like injustice for
all like i i like stuff pre-black albums
but why the lightning is incredible it
is amazing but master of puppets is
amazing too but i i of course like the
black album but then there was that
weird fuel phase where they cut their
hair and got earrings and stuff but i'm
just gonna go out and live and said they
were delightful then too i gotta i gotta
ask great you're you're running for
office
and you're not wearing a suit you're
wearing a metallica t-shirt i have to
wonder if there's some like highly paid
consultants like sean listen you go on
the show you wanna relate to
working-class people wear a metallica
shirt you know you you know i don't fit
the mold of it of a typical politician i
i just don't um and you know there are
people out there that are critical of me
for what i wear
um but you know what i um i am who i am
and that's just it and uh i i dress
appropriately when i spoke at the
convention i wore a suit when i'm when
i'm in when i'm trump yeah yeah wear
suits when i need to but have you ever
seen that movie the um
let me just say that what do you ever
see a politician in campaign season do
they wear a business suit in the
commercials that they run
not usually not usually why but they
were like polos and khakis yeah well
yeah yeah yeah
i don't do that either but my point is
is that there's a reason why when
they're running ads in their district
they're not wearing a three-piece suit
it's because
it's not have you ever seen the
adjustment bureau i think it's called
the movie just oh yeah yeah it's a good
one yeah so it's basically in the
beginning he's running for congress i
guess and then he just has this moment
of clarity where he's like
this tie was picked for me by a
consultant
these shoes are the perfect amount of
scuffed we don't want to look like slobs
but we don't want to offend the working
class and then everyone loves it and
ends up running again but the movie's
about you ask my consultants about
working with me as a kid i kind of just
sort of
kind of just do my thing they're like
we're a nickelback shirt and you're like
that's wrong that's bad advice so much
all right let's read some more i can't
that's a that's a bridge too
far but you'll get the nickelback vote
what the canadian vote
in pennsylvania maybe with mail-in
ballots i don't know i don't know gone
fall says larry the chad elder for gov
that's right
michael fernando says great work tim
cass crew important topics and
interesting guests did y'all see ron
paul's video about the great unraveling
not feeling very good about the future
of the us and the world freedom must win
i haven't i will check that out that's
interesting
little bear says tim poole i don't give
legal advice also tim poole joe rogan
should sue cnn new zealand
i'll answer that new zealand we're
banning knives evan dmt the fed like and
share um what i mean by specifically
advice is like
specific tactics
so when when someone comes on the show
and they're like look i'm not a lawyer
i'm not giving legal advice
but if you look at the law in this
section and file on this and this this
they're not saying like man sue them sue
them like that's a very very blunt thing
like i'll say sue them i'll say go to a
doctor and figure out what you need to
help yourself and go to a financial
advisor
saying sue them is more on par with like
go to a lawyer and challenge them i'm
not saying that joe should specifically
use
certain legal tactics
or that i am giving him advice on how he
should file his paperwork and what he
should claim
that's a little different but admittedly
legal financial medical device are all
very different things and there's
probably different thresholds but uh you
know that being said
all right let's see what we got here a
lot of people saying larry the chad
elder appreciate the super chats
nemo sundry says i work in the youth and
housing non-profit programs an entire
dependence victimhood culture is
consuming the industry i've been
targeted and ostracized by social
justice going public exposing the crisis
real empowerment equals
self-determination theory
interesting
all right
marleno tk says i think rogan should sue
to help validate some potential uses of
the so-called horse dewormer maybe it
would provoke more trials and research i
think larry should sue
larry i think
joe rogan should sue because they lied
about him as to whether or not he has a
case i don't know i can't advise him on
that i think you just sued a punished
a journalist
yeah yeah i think you just take every
chance you can
to
take a scalp with these people yeah i
mean joe certainly has the resources to
do a legal carpet box and there's no
accountability for the false stuff that
they push
ever they can push these false stories
they don't get banned they hurt people
in some cases and
the news cycle changes and no one's ever
held accountable so
if you want media to change
you have to go at them when they commit
grievous wrongs
cal miller says sean did trump give you
his secret to looking younger now oh
usually people age 20 years after being
the president this is this is i i think
we need to address this right so the
picture that i took with president trump
has generated some controversy on the
internet
i've gotten oh that's a body double or
that's not really trump or
the president had plastic surgery look i
don't know instagram filters or maybe
maybe they're just like photoshopping
maybe there was a little face tuning
going on i don't know uh maybe no no it
was a good yeah so
um my people were saying it's it's a
good pick but but anyway i met president
trump when i i and this was a few weeks
ago and i thought
he looks so good he looks like he lost
50 pounds he looks in the best shape of
his life and
and that is
the we're making this news here that is
a a real picture of president trump he
looks fantastic he looks like he's in
really good shape but is it
is he doing that so that he can be
healthy for
2024. you want i'm a betting man if i'm
a betting man he's running in 2024. this
is unofficial i don't know president
trump never told me anything but like
he's
he is very very fired up about
he's got so many awesome things uh
working and he's planning and he's laser
focused on i mean he's laser focused on
taking back the house and the senate and
we just got his endorsement the other
day and that is a it's a game changer
because even in the state of
pennsylvania and there are a lot of
people say oh you gotta you gotta you
know pennsylvania is a tough spot
president trump was the most popular
republican president in the history of
pennsylvania that's just by the numbers
and so
uh
yeah he still has an unbelievable amount
of support there but yes the real
picture it was a real picture chance
jones with a question for sean what's
your opinion on afghanistan and if you
get elected in the senate will you
actually do anything or what tells uh do
anything or what to tell us what your
goals are
well how much time do you have on
afghanistan well i think afghanistan is
a wholly preventable uh tragedy i i
support after 20 years of war there i
support
um uh drawing down in afghanistan i mean
i'm 40 i turned 40 in july we were we've
been at war in that country for half of
half of my life it was time to come i
was wounded there
lost a lot of my friends in that country
probably over 40 people that were very
close friends of mine that i've lost in
that country and so you know my number
one promise to the people of
pennsylvania is that i am not a um i
hate war i've seen it up close and
personal and i hate it i think that
america's sons and daughters are our
most precious natural resource and by
god if we're going to send them into the
fight and sometimes
that is necessary because freedom is
worth fighting for and we're dying for
and sometimes our country is is
threatened but
by god there's sure there's her sec
better be a clear-cut mission in
clear-cut end state because what
happened in afghanistan uh you know 20
years of
blood and treasure sacrificed in that
country
only to have joe biden throw it all away
in eight months with uh just a botched
withdrawal plan um
didn't have to be this way
boom chuck says tim you spent the last
few years telling everyone not to
confront the left or to resort to the
left's violent tactics don't call us
cowards now that is a absolute that is
an absolute false statement of fact i've
consistently said stand up speak up and
uh
and challenge all of this stuff but i've
specifically said violence doesn't work
because it'll just be used against you
because well for one you're fighting
uphill peaceful persuasive resourceful
gaining control of institutions getting
the right jobs how many people on the
right are applying at the new york times
get a job at the new york times
there you go go apply go apply for a job
there go apply to go seriously everybody
right now pick your media company gawker
just restarted everybody apply you live
in new york and you're not woke well
apply for the job don't come out and
start screaming maga 2024 when they're
hiring you but you get these jobs
tal you you understand the place you
work and you roll with the punches and
then slowly start you know being friends
with people and influencing uh
influencing people and there you go
getting the gain the uh the edge like uh
they gaining the institutions do the
same thing
back
all right let's grab some of these oh
what's this
all right let's see where we're at we'll
try and find a good one
sean bachman says texas abortion law
would it be possible to bipartisan
pro-life legislation through that bans
the death penalty and abortion oh
great question is it possible yeah
absolutely not the left would never go
for that the left is right is so
radically radically pro-abortion today
that they
that they that they that they refused to
vote for the born alive act that would
protect babies that were born alive do
they even care about the death penalty
anymore right right is that even an
issue that i don't know here's here's
there's there's an interesting paradox
um with the left they claim the death
penalty is wrong but they're in favor of
abortion and they can't define when life
begins it's always different you ask any
most people on the left will give you
various answers they can't define when
life begins i think like ian you
mentioned it was brain activity yeah
something like that uh first
trimester-ish but i i think
that literally makes no makes no sense
you know life begins at conception when
we have a human life is when the brain i
think that you're it's a living husk of
meat and then eventually we become a
human and then you know that's right
i don't think that that's i don't i
don't think that that's i i don't know
that this the science supports that i
and i by the way i threw up in my mouth
a little bit when the science supports
that because i think it's just that term
trust the science is like so overused
but i mean i think it's pretty clear
that at conception it's a human life
well the zygote uh is indistinguishable
from other animal zygotes and only
through evolution or through growth
it's only life if you find that on mars
yeah yeah like if if if we have uh
cells in a petri dish it's life if we
have uh and there's restrictions on like
certain things you can do and if you
have like a fertilized chicken egg for
instance it's living
and you see you see what happens in the
morning you see the mark did you have
you seen the march for life this year uh
this this year right
um there were some more young people
there than i'd ever seen before in my
life and i think the reason for that is
is that the science is
is on our side i think you know it's
pretty clear now that it at conception
is the moment where human life i'm not
even like um
hardcore about i can tell i can tell i'm
not even yeah i think that it's
inevitably going to continue and if we
try to make it illegal we'll create a
bunch of criminals that's one of my big
fears about legislating it
so we got janet west says tim the puzzle
piece you're missing is that it's not
uncommon for doctors to prescribe
off-label drugs as long as fda approved
and safe uh i'm not missing that puzzle
piece i think it's actually very simple
and that's why i'm telling people to go
to their doctors the weirdest thing to
me is that people are like yes but my
doctor you know can prescribe things off
label i'm like then why are you saying
like what's your concern with me saying
i don't know i don't agree but your
doctor will make the decision that's
like you know what i mean like if
it seems like people genuinely believe
doctors will only tell them a mainstream
narrative when we've literally had
guests on the show who have talked about
how their doctors advised them to or not
to get the vaccine we've had doctors on
the show that have
talked about mainstream right right yeah
exactly lots of them and so i'm just
like
i understand there's off label
prescriptions that's why when joe rogan
talks about what he was prescribed i'm
like hey that's between joe and his
doctor don't look at me i'm not a doctor
go talk to joe's doctor if you're
concerned right all right let's find uh
let's let's see what we got
all right let's see
stephen marsh says this is for ian i
think the best way to describe rights is
that they come from natural instinct you
have the right to self-defense because
it's human instinct to do so when
attacked and and other example i don't
have room for
i don't i don't agree with that
i think that's that's probably put but
but ian doesn't believe in rights
that's not true
well yeah it is what do you mean no i
mean i think the way we derive our
rights are is up for debate you know in
the constitution it says that they come
from god i feel like they come from the
barrel of a gun
yeah the only rights the only rights you
have are the ones that you can defend
yeah i mean
then if it's a right but you can't
defend it then it's
theoretical no i think it's still a i
think you probably agree more with ian
on this then the right exists just
because someone infringes upon it
doesn't mean you've lost the right it
just means they've infringed upon it but
i mean like ecuador uh tribes in ecuador
until like 1950 believed it was a right
that you could just kill a tribe member
and eat them right but because people
have a right to self-defense there's
some things that are
more discernibly true than others right
like oh it's my right to kill nietzsche
if that were the case then you'd have to
just submit to them doing it
but you're right to defend yourself and
say no that's actually not your right
because now i'm going to end you for
trying to harm me but rights are also
cultural though
yeah so so i i agree and disagree i
think that there are certain things that
are obvious and intrinsic i certainly
think there are people on the right and
the left that believe that there are
rights that that are intrinsic that
aren't like health care human rights is
not true and there are certain things
people think are rights well actually
i think you have a lot of rights a lot i
think mostly this refers to just what
you can do
uh
it's hard to define but typically
without
violating the you know non-aggression
principle i don't i don't know well
there's positive rights and there's
negative rights right and
yeah i think positive rights are mostly
good libertarians believe in negative
rights exactly if you meet a libertarian
and you're like wow this person really
sucks in everything they believe and
they sound like a leftist they believe
in positive rights right but negative
rights are where it's at yeah positive
rights i think i'm sure there's some
nuance here but most mostly make no
sense at all like health care being a
human right is a positive right that
makes no sense someone has to give it to
you or provide it for you you can't
force someone to do that
but i think if you're in the middle of
the woods
you can do a lot of things that no one
can stop you from doing and that means
there's a lot of really awful things you
could probably do to yourself like you
mentioned putting whatever you want in
your own body i'm like
a lot of people would argue you don't
have that right but you literally do you
can eat a pine cone if you want but i
don't think that's bad
recommend against eating a pine cone but
you know some people want to eat pine
gums i guess i you know and there's also
pica and i think people shouldn't do
that
there there is there is a challenge
though i mean if you saw someone eating
pennies wouldn't you stop them
would i stop them yeah
if i loved them i'd stop them
it's it it's not it's it's not always so
easy i guess there's a lot of things we
think we know i did not advise against
it
all right little tails farm says tim we
just got an 8 by 16 tiny home slash
coupe delivered today and started
building our version of chicken city
gonna film it start to finish and post
it on our channel thanks for the
encouragement for this absolutely we
just started trenching for our chicken
city
we have five black star babies yes
so uh yes they are little poof balls for
those that aren't aware and i'm not
going to be an expert on chickens or
anything but we have a rhode island red
rooster and we have bard plymouth rock
hens two of them well the rooster and
the hens got together they had a whole
lot of fun we took the eggs we incubated
12. none of them survived except the
black star so black star is a sex link
it means that if you take the specific
rooster and hand and put them together
you get a very specific offspring where
the boys have little white spots on
their heads and the girls don't so you
can easily tell them apart
but the crazy thing is if you then mix
the black stars together you don't get
the same you get just a a mix it's like
it's it's really crazy how that works
and so there's a couple other i guess we
can do i think we we're able to do red
star chickens as well that by hybriding
with the red rooster so this will be a
lot of fun and then we have
three goofy looking babies that hatched
that we've been filming for a while it's
uh we think it's two hens in a rooster
and uh the rooster's name is officially
roberto jr because roberto is the
rooster and it's his first son and then
we're trying to figure out the names i
guess it's sally and alex we're naming
the two hens and the reason we chose
alex is because we think it's a hen but
we're not entirely sure so hey this name
is safe there you go and then we're
gonna be building um
chicken city now the challenge is we
have three black star roosters
i don't know we're gonna do with a bunch
of roosters
chicken city sounds something that would
be like on the office like michael scott
would come up with like in the break
room i i cannot wait to see the finished
product
yeah we're gonna have cameras all around
it live streaming 24 7. yes
awesome the reason we uh it's been a
long time coming is because we wanted to
do it with the existing coop we have but
it's ill-equipped to handle the chickens
properly and so we're rebuilding a
better one
so that it's easier for us to clean
easier for easier for us to move in and
out of and collect eggs and things like
that easier easier for us to put cameras
and the issue uh i'll i'll be you you
guys want to know why this is taking so
long to get all stuff done
no no no people working nobody's working
no joke
we're trying to find people who want to
do a lot of the work and it's it's it's
hard uh it's hard to find workers and i
know we have a lot of emails for a lot
of jobs but i mean like legit
contractors who can be like i can hammer
this out and get it done instantly
in the area
we're going as fast as we can and it's
not so easy too a lot of people are
there's a lot of people also who are
like you know i'll come out and i'll
help it's like yes but it's also like
getting the materials getting supplies
yeah there are periods where it's like
the guys who are working are like yeah
we gotta wait for the wood to come in
and it's just like
the supply chain disruptions and labor
shortages across the board ripple all
the way down to us building a chicken
coop yep
all right let's see what we got what we
got
popular liberty says chaos gives the
state more power that's my friend andrew
there you go cool yeah he
he has some ideas for local politics
that are going to blow people away oh
exciting yeah andrew
braziwell says very excited to see pete
on now that you've had him on michael
malus dave smith and scott horton you
only need to have on tom woods and bob
murphy to complete your top tier austro
libertarian podcaster collection
bob murphy huh
great idea
he was just on jordan he was just down
with peterson he's on my list my
shortlist watcher of shadows says i'm
sorry but the idea the us should break
up is stupid unless you plan to learn
mandarin
i i actually agree with that really you
you what what did uh hirohito say what
did he say a gun behind everybody blade
of grass i don't know that he actually
said that but it sounds cool but
but it makes sense if you know
once you get once you get off the coasts
so i suppose the bigger issue is but if
so okay so
switzerland has been sitting in
the middle of europe a small country i
think it's 21 cantons it's broken up and
they've avoided war for
over three four centuries now they
avoided two world wars
why
why is that the banks are located
everyone has a gun
everyone all of these things are right
yeah
they're not a threat to anybody
and they were mountainous so before
gunpowder they couldn't get taken they'd
try and they had these long likes
the united states has gone into is
dropping bombs in seven countries right
now
and
i think a lot of people look at them as
a threat yeah i think that's a really
bad thing but i don't think you uh that
the learn mandarin is imp is implying
that china invades the united states
it's implying that china's influence
grows so substantially and controls so
much of the resources of the planet
china's second largest mortgage company
ever grand
is
their bonds were just taken off the
market
what does that mean that means that they
they're basically out of business
blackrock took their no this is because
china has done in 25 years to their
economy what the federal reserve has
been doing for a hundred years in this
country they've
their g let's see they were 100 their
debt was 100 of gdp in 1995 it's now 255
of or 250 five times which is basically
ours so their debts piling up but the
problem is they don't have a central
bank they don't have a janet yellen they
don't have a paul volcker to guide them
and keep them going they're financially
dying right now to the point where i can
pull up articles of people
calling for cultural revolutions and
they're not calling for cultural and if
what if these cultural revolutions
happen it's not going to be pointed at
us it's going to be pointed inwards at
their own people
i think that i think that china
anyone who is saying that china is this
insanely
insane threat as far as financial
systems go does not read david stockman
who is ronald reagan's budget director
was in the white house with ronald
reagan's budget director
doesn't read zero hedge and
just isn't up to date on what their
economy is doing right now i mean they
are dying
you know everybody's oh their gdp is so
amazing yeah those cities that they
build that no one lives in that's part
of their gdp
that's well i thought it was like uh
like eight or so years ago people
started moving in and they've been
building up
oh they still have those cities the
ghosts there's a lot of them but i'm
pretty sure they start moving people in
but they're
at this point so here's another great
little stat
in this country one percent of one per
farming
either by machine either by a hand or by
animal is what is done by one percent of
farmers
30 percent of the farmers in
in china are still either farming by
hand or plowing yeah
i mean they're they have a higher rate
of diabetes right now than we do geez
wow
i mean this is
whoever is feeding i mean sure of course
they are to be worried about
because
they control they're so big a part of
our economy but watch what's happening
to them financially right now they are
in
tons of trouble there's a book by
a harvard professor called unrivaled you
wrote it in 2018 he goes through all
these demographics about china and just
and this is a warhawk
and he comes to the conclusion that
these are
we're not supposed to worry about these
people
and this is this is a this isn't a
realist this isn't an anti-war guy this
is a guy who would say okay we need to
do something
and this book on rival just
breaks it down as to why china is just
in so much trouble we'll do one more
ed'sworld says does ian believe in god
doubtful
well
i think that there is you got to define
god that's that's my lifelong goal one
of them i think that cosmic microwave
background radiation is likely
interfering with matter like solids
liquids and gases and causing what we
perceive as god
so
i i definitely there's something there
like there's a
you know there's some some energy
flowing
whether or not it's intelligent i don't
know it seems to move intelligently you
know the way i see it as kind of like
do people believe that they are the
supreme intelligence of the universe or
at least that that there is life within
the universe that is
that there is nothing else above it or
is there something above the universe
the way i see it is like
anything that exists within the universe
is certainly below
the the the construct itself or or
whatever this higher system is that
which we exist and so god clearly exists
in that in that sense
yeah and tim a couple like last week
mentioned the uh like sub-atomic
fluctuations and like you see the
spinners and all this this so i i talked
about it like it's the cmbr that cosmic
microwave background radiation but
that's just like the radiation that's
just the energy like the i don't know if
it's just electrons or plasma or what
but it could be it's got to be more than
that i i see it like do you think that
the universe is a flat plane on which
you are standing and it's meaningless
and random or do you believe that the
system in place is more powerful and
above you
or even beyond that could there be
something that exists beyond the
universe as we know it and i think even
if we're looking at like m theory and
you know multiple dimensions and stuff
and the answer is clearly yes in which
case humans are so far away from any
kind of higher life it's easy to it's
easy to say math should predict a higher
form of intelligent life somewhere
somehow even if it's something we create
with computers but if that's certainly
capable of existing there's certainly
higher powers than human beings the
problem is that people define god as
like a guy in the clouds who's you know
snapping his fingers to make things
appear when it could be
so far beyond our comprehension that we
couldn't even describe yeah i got to get
away from the guy god being a guy that
that really disturbs me when they say he
gave us this that i feel like is brain
like catholic brainwashing patriarchy
and actually that's language
and you know i call it a man is weird to
me
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do this we'll
go over to uh start producing this here
bonus members only segment so make sure
you go to temcast.com sign up you can uh
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
on instagram tick tock twitter whatever
i don't you we'll put up the you know
the addresses but you can follow me
personally at tim cast uh you want to
shout anything out john oh yeah can i
can i promote my book is that cool
so my book just came out uh a couple
days ago right i think this week it's
it's called left for dead a lot of books
i know i have five now you've not read
you've
but someone does uh but look this the
book is called left 4 dead
what i try to do is like look at where
we are as a country and say if we stay
on this path we could be here well
i mean
sometimes i'm proud when i get it right
uh this time i'm not uh because we've
got americans left behind surrounded by
global jihadists in afghanistan right
now we've got to do everything we can to
get them out but
but this just this just came out like
if you can manage it grab a copy like it
would be an honor
but yeah this is i'm i'm psyched i'm
psyched about it where do people get it
oh you can get it anywhere books are
sold um yeah it's that anyway amazon
whatever but try to find it somewhere
other than amazon
or whatever i guess whatever
as much as i don't like amazon the the
great thing about it is if everyone buys
the book and it gets it to number one
then that's free promotion on a massive
plan this look it is this is a huge deal
uh to to it's very very difficult to to
make the new york times best seller list
i i've made that list before i am a new
york times bestselling author but but
for fiction it's really hard because
you'll have you know john grisham and
stephen king and all these heavyweights
that yeah yeah uh jk rowling that will
have books on there all year and so it's
hard for a guy like me to to make it
uh on that list but also if if it this
senate race right in in polit politics
if if saving this country is so
important
is important to you
then then contribute to my campaign
because it's just
my campaign is driven by small dollar
donors we had 45 000 individual donors
uh
uh in 2020
if i'm beholden to anybody it's to the
people and if you want to win if you
want to save this country we have to win
pennsylvania so go to parnell for senate
dot com and chip in if you can
uh how many l's in parnell two two
parnell for senate dot com and and then
and
yeah yeah help me win pennsylvania and
save america because because we have to
there's a zero-sum game in 2022. so
free man be on the wall podcast
obviously if i'm having videos taken
down off of youtube i'm probably doing
something right
yeah and um check out our documentary on
amazon the monopoly on violence
uh thanks for thanks for coming guys
i've been really beat up about this
afghanistan surrender it's it's almost
almost destroyed my mind so thanks for
being here with us uh the last week and
this last week's been really rough for
me too so so apologize if i've come off
a little aggressive but uh
how are we gonna do i don't know
thanks for being here anyway catch you
later love you
i started listening to peter's
documentary on the way to pick him up
this afternoon and it is a wonderful
documentary and they start way back in
history which is exactly what i want
from my documentaries i want to get the
full story and it sounds awesome so
check out the monopoly on violence thank
you bye peter quinones and you guys can
follow me
at
sourpatchlidsontwitter.com as i attempt
to have more followers and sour patch
kids very important we will see you all
over at timcast.com in the members
segment should be around 11 or so pm
thanks for hanging out we'll see you
there
you